yo this is whack 100 catch me on a
hundred episode of the bullet cad
podcast and uh yo kev delete that delete
that i don't want people to hear that
delete that bro for real delete that
it's the bootleg head podcast 100th
episode
so we recorded like an hour and a half
with you and then you left
and then like 10 minutes after you left
there was this headline uh about you
leaving a comment about how much money
you've lined up for six nine and then
there's some audio that's out there now
and we had just had this we just had
this long conversation
that was a little i guess that wasn't
out there yet so i was like yo whack you
got to come back in so this is the
beginning of the interview you're going
to keep watching this there's there's a
lot of gems throughout the rest of the
interview but there is some six nine
stuff that might be a little dated so
whack let me just start this
are you managing six nine definitely not
i think at
this time in six nine career
um
and from what he's been through
the word manager is not appealing to him
right it'll take for anybody that wants
to beat at the six nine
you're gonna have to be in the box with
him and do a bunch of business for him
to stop in some type of trust
but um
i don't think six nine is
manageable to a point
so where he's gonna let somebody control
the narrative
would you like what he will
or has allowed
is
for me to utilize his name
and the buildings that i have some say
so we're in and relationships in to do
some business if it's dead
if he came to you and said whack i would
want you to be my manager would you
consider it
um
at this point in time
i couldn't be a hundred percent
management to six nine
could you be like a co-manager with the
murder murderer with the murder murphy
guy whoever definitely i wouldn't do
that either what i would do
is i have a lot of management teams out
there a lot of people that i'm friends
with that i'm real cool with that i know
that understand this business like i
understand it i would probably negotiate
something with them and put them in
place but at this time where he's at
right um
a full
time manager is not what he needs he
just needs somebody that has
the resources and the reach
to get things done you got to remember
before he left he would run around with
a bunch of street dudes claiming to be a
manager right right i used to be the
street dude that didn't understand the
industry so i used to be that guy i
understand the difference between the
street dude claiming the title versus
really living that title you know what i
mean of course so
i think what a lot of people see like
watch this
who's little nas ex manager i have no
[ __ ] idea you know why
because their management team operates
from a building
the cell phone to attorneys and they
send their little assistant guy out to
make sure shit's done right what you
guys are used to whack doing is i'm
hands on with my artists and we know
right we know like whack manages
blueface we know whack manages games ray
j et cetera yeah i'm hands-on with my
artists so when people see them they see
me you yes it's a direct thing right
um with a guy like
six nine
right um something like that probably
will be set up what would he ask me one
day hey whack
could you set me up or do you know these
dudes he probably would because
in a short period of time all i've done
was you got a product
right six nine let's take away all the
[ __ ] he's a product
right when you're talking about business
right yeah entertainment business you
have a product if i got this phone right
mm-hmm and this is the six nine phone
right
and i know that i have distribution
reach
in 12 countries
because of my prior relationships
i can box this phone up
mail it out to each country my liaison
and say hey
can you guys do something with this
phone
they're going to say well whack
we heard a few things about this phone
but are we dealing with you directly and
i'm going to say yeah you're dealing
with me directly
you won't have to deal
with the guy on the phone right and they
say okay whack based upon me our
relationship yeah we could distribute
five million phones a year for you
right
okay my attorney will be in touch with
you at that point in time is it be a
contract a letter of direction
and a signature
so you know what i'm saying essentially
essentially what you're doing is
contracting your your services to six
nine no what i'm doing is
um like like you're setting up pleasure
you're making sure you have to listen he
has a
he has a value to himself right right
and i have resources for the things
that's valuable
about this young kid right so simply
what i'm doing is i'm just bringing them
together bringing them together and
you're getting your cut that's it
obviously oh definitely yeah that's
business that is business
so
and it's not a uh
extra cut on top of a cut
because he is who he is
you know what i mean some people would
say well [ __ ] that
uh you putting your name on the line you
should get 50 instead of
what you would normally get what you
would normally get right
and you know some people might want to
play it like that right but in my world
it's like you know greed you know you
greed don't get you nowhere you know
what i mean do what you do
take it keep it moving maybe y'all do
some more business later maybe you won't
but if you gouge a person it's a good
chance you won't especially if you know
today in the situation where they might
have to do it you know what i'm saying a
person knows that then they know that he
could have gouged me
but he didn't
you know i mean i've gotten all kind of
phone calls movies nft touring
uh i mean [ __ ] it you name it crazy [ __ ]
goddamn
i ain't gonna name the endorsement but
people contact my attorney mm-hmm
my attorney for 469. yeah my attorney
well they contact my attorney because
they're like well whack we can can we
talk to you we've been wanting to do
this business
right
so can we send this to you
and can you let us know if this could
happen hey listen bro uh i understand
why guys in the streets are saying what
they're saying
about you working with them the reason
why i understand them because i used to
be that guy
when i was like 15 years old
right i don't expect that guy to
understand what i'm doing because that
guy
hasn't elevated he don't even understand
business
he probably still hustling in the
streets whatever he's doing right so i
understand his mindset because i used to
have that mindset right when i was
adolescent right um
corporate america in the streets
two total different worlds i mean that's
what you're saying uh you'll see later
on in the interview where you were
talking about people up on that 50th
floor yeah yeah
there's not a lot of people get on that
floor you know what i mean i don't know
nobody has uh
hand-picked me and said you're gonna be
the one to go in and represent us and
none of that you know it does sound like
though you're kind of like
doing a lot of stuff with a that a
manager would do for him
well um i don't know because i can't
tell you what six nine's life can
consist of day to day you asked me about
game ray j blue face i can tell you
pretty much day to day week by week of
course month by month because you're
extremely hands on what we got to do
right right right i can't tell you what
he's doing i can't tell you where he is
right now what he has to do tomorrow the
only thing i can elaborate on if
somebody calls me and tells me
hey man we want to do a tour from
january 15 to [ __ ] march and i can
say well from january 15 he'll be on
tour in europe right if that was the
case right i know that because it's been
contracted so i don't you know i don't
know what his
day-to-day what he's doing what other
situation he's doing all his deals and
all this paperwork i don't know who's
overseeing those things some would say
like at least from my perspective i
think like if he's ever gonna be
relevant again musically
he almost needs a whack 100.
no
because i'm not saying i don't mean i
don't i don't make his music
i wouldn't know how to make his music
but i just think it makes the the six
nine pill a little easier to swallow if
whack 100 is
that's what y'all keep getting it wrong
at
the wac 100 crowd
right
is no different than the blue face crowd
they don't give a [ __ ] what i think now
the game crowd
is my crowd right it's people from my
generation and a little under me that
that's his fan base
uh the six nine crowd wouldn't give a
[ __ ] if it was whack 100 a daffy duck or
nobody at all
they're into his music i couldn't even
tell you the chemistry of this young
man's music i don't know what producers
he worked with so you haven't been
helping him at all with music or maybe
getting features never been in the
studio with him i've never done anything
like that i don't really need a feature
personally but you've heard the new
music
oh definitely and i heard about four
songs what are your what's your opinion
on it oh you got some hits they hits
they're hits i've called in people that
hate his guts radio right
hate six nine guts
and they said
i hate the fact
that i like this music and i hate this
individual right
the product is the product
it ain't you know it's not my kind of
music
right uh but his fan base
yeah he
he's there uh what i will say is
um if i have anything to do with
any other music we definitely have
understanding that there's no uh
disrespecting anybody
dead homies or
uh any artist in particular you know
what i'm saying whatever i touch gotta
be just music
and i think really he's at a point in
his career but he shouldn't have to do
that anymore anyway so you guys you
pretty much have an agreement with him
that if you do get involved on the music
side that the disrespect has to
anything i touch i mean i don't know he
might go do some other random [ __ ]
that's his business i can't control that
but if i'm touching it
right it can't it can't be you know i
mean you talking about you know
somebody's dead right right [ __ ] like
that i'm really not off into that so
is that something that you think is
gonna end up happening where you're kind
of like
helping him out on the music side
um i've i've looked at his contracts
because i needed to understand that um
uh um
was what
you know what i mean because it's a lot
of things that goes along with you know
publishing deals and and things of that
nature he still signed the who he signed
to right you know that's still a
business you know but i will look at his
contract
because if he has any questions about
what's going on or what's not going on i
need to be able to answer that right
which you know i got a legal team you
know my uh attorney sam rossing he's one
of the best in the business so he
overlooks everything to see was what was
what and i'm not really here to ruffle
any feathers at his label
to take him from one label to another
label
his comfort zone is where it's been it
really needs to be there right but if a
question is asked to me i need to be
able to answer that i understand that
because if i'm doing business over here
let's say a movie situation they say hey
we want him to do the soundtrack right i
need to understand what his obligations
to his label is can this be done they'll
just have to run through his label this
is something that can be done
independently you know without going
that direction so that that's the reason
why i looked through those type of
things the 43 million dollars of
business you've set up is this a little
more than that but it's a little bit
more than that right you got to remember
you talking about the artist man that's
good for like five to eight thousand
tickets that ain't never been on tour
just you do the math
you know what i'm saying so that so that
that uh vastly is
live show well you got it you got now
you got a fight in there it's 20 million
so the blue face fight yep you got nft
deals in there multiple nft deals and
you set all this up crazy uh
you got publishing situations that's
crazy you quarterbacked it all you got
torn european torn that's you know
that's crazy you got to remember
all my
tours
i route me and my wife route
and you guys have been in europe i have
a liaison on the other side named finn
but all my tours i i route you know my
wife does all the uh
cos's and the
uh the clearance passport clearances i
do the booking all the hotels the back
line game travels with a band
tour busting flight you handle it all i
do all that [ __ ] on this phone yeah no
agency ain't none of that right so uh
it's nothing all the fairy cost all bus
routing you know remember i own the
trucking business 20 something years so
it's the same [ __ ] so i do all of that
so it's just a simple text blast hey
listen you know give me some feedback on
what you guys could do
right he's just a ring he's an arena
artist
so when you think about it it's a lot of
money man yeah you think about it you
you talking about a minimum of 350 that
can go up to access to you know once you
do your back end cut up or your splits
at the doors of merger seven seven
hundred fifty thousand dollars a night
so it really ain't no money that i put
out there's some money but if you do the
math on that it accumulates adds up
and i mean yeah i mean [ __ ] that's a lot
do we know any sort of window when uh we
can this fight's gonna happen
um it's not gonna happen in the u.s
okay um
so it's gonna probably be overseas
middle east saudi arabia somewhere dubai
or something uh probably not dubai dubai
and bahrain may come together and
do something with saudi saudi's kind of
making the move to be like dubai
so we're looking at putting it over
there the good thing about it is the
actual minister of finance of
entertainment over there is the one
handling it personally oh wow yeah but
that's a resource that's the resource i
have yeah you brought together i can
reach right there i ain't got to go over
here
so you know at the end of the day
it'll happen over there but even with
that that's just a flat fee you know
once it's announced now you got to think
about you know taking starbucks
pay-per-views or maybe you know [ __ ]
sponsorships sponsorships are going to
come so that's just business man and i i
don't know maybe i've i've matured and
grown to a point to where
some [ __ ] don't matter to me
the [ __ ] that used to matter to you that
would keep you up at night like don't
don't i mean at the end of the day we
all involved yeah i mean listen it was a
point in my life this real [ __ ] that if
i was out in public
and uh me and my homeboys and somebody
told me yo that's that [ __ ] calf dog
for [ __ ] san diego
yeah we rolled him up off the yard cause
he snitched on the [ __ ] right
i'm not from san diego i wasn't on the
yard don't know him at a point in my
life i'd have did something to that man
just because of the politics that i was
under
right
today you could tell me hey yo
that's such a sudden
such and such i don't give a [ __ ]
ben is something is mine it's not my
business whoever need to deal with that
need to deal with that
for real now
i'm a strong belief in
street business street conversation
street talk
my homeboys in my neighborhood
other don moves or whatever the [ __ ] you
know i mean i would never use the value
of a bag or any of that to bring that
around six nine because that was part of
this problem when that element comes
around he feeds off into it and i really
think he needs another element around
him he needs a more uh him leaning into
the youtube [ __ ] he's perfect he needs a
more uh you know
uh
you know
toddler creator type
surrounding around here somebody that's
not he's hanging out with steve will do
it which is perfect i don't know if you
know the elk boy dudes but that's he's
on the elk boys like every week i think
that's like right up his yeah he needs
to get in his lane bro and be around his
people you know what i mean and how to
proper people around you know what i
mean like like my my demographic and
what i bring is not
what needs to be around him every day
you know i got a little crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
i got game that's a g pirate you know i
mean i got ray j that is what he is you
know i mean so i gotta maintain those
elements to make sure
my people are straight i can't
put that around that because it's
totally contradicting of what i'm saying
he should've never been a part of um you
you and my son have had uh some words
before on the internet he's someone who
used to be affiliated with the game back
in the day right um i mean he went on a
tour too right right i didn't know if he
was ever black wall street officials
never he went on a tour but uh you know
he's somebody who's obviously no
disrespect my son is is it i'm not gonna
say was my man he's still my man it was
just getting a little weird because
we've always done our debates right i
was gonna say it seems like it's a
at least a semi-respectful disagreement
at least
yeah i saw what he put up last night and
i i think my son's like a great leader
like you know as far as you know
everything that's been going on i mean
just always you can look for my song for
like direction as far as like if you
want to know i mean that's what he
turned himself into he's kind of like
this like martin luther king type um
revolutionary type dude which is kind of
confusing because like yo listen if you
that stop telling my street [ __ ]
my sign and like that's my man i didn't
see my sign by myself it's all love like
you know it's people that's in new york
got to tell you they didn't hurt me and
my sign orchestrating [ __ ] over the
phone that's my man like i don't want to
see that happen to him i don't got in my
heart to do nothing to him but on the
flip side my side i had nothing to say
when you was running around with vlad we
all knew
uh you know rick ross never said nothing
either [ __ ] suing rick ross lawsuits
criminal cases and fouling [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying cause rick ross then
whooped on vlad ass you talking some
street [ __ ] you run around with vlad but
you know why you was running around with
vlad because vlad was giving you your
exposed platform your platform which is
business i understood that was business
understood that you wasn't running
around with vlad saying [ __ ] this vlad
tv a nut [ __ ] would ever come with you
wasn't doing that you were utilizing
that platform because vlad is a big
plastic huge platform and you were doing
your rap thing or whatever it is you was
doing and i was working for you right i
didn't say hey my son
and we talked i got long phone history
with my son text messages for years
right hey my son on some real street
[ __ ]
what you doing with vlad
you know he doing that to rick ross a
street [ __ ]
it was business
but i don't know i think maybe he runs
out of things to talk about and if he
runs out of things to talk about by all
means there's a brother he can utilize
my name to bring some publicity to him i
ain't mad at that it's entertainment i
ain't tripping no i mean that's that's
that's a yeah i'm not a very mature way
of looking at it i'm not trying okay we
talked before the camera's rolling and
i'm not going to use anything all my
people let it be known yeah my sign in
my book
is not my enemy
everybody that loved me that i just
moved for me without saying no i don't
want nobody ever to approach my son in a
threatening way or question him about
anything that got to do with wag 100
that's between me and my son
period you know what i'm saying period
some real [ __ ]
um
i want to kind of peel the curtain back
a bit without mentioning any direct
names or
albums but um
you had said essentially
let's have the conversation we have
before the camera's rolling but let's
exclude all names right
that you had helped a recent project
yeah
hit
a crazy amount of streams it's first
week yeah and we're talking
a big big project we'll let people guess
in the in the comments but you know
there's only been a few of these
projects that have dropped this year
that everyone's talked about
so explain what happened and and um kind
of peel back the curtain a bit on the
industry and how a lot of this i mean
listen i'ma say it in so many times
the process of music
it starts with the artist the appearance
of the artist
the uh you know the studio time the
production all that mix mastering
right the video and all that after that
comes the marketing mm-hmm right you
can't spin
to our indie guys
10 15 000 on the song
and then nothing on marketing mm-hmm
bigger the artist is the bigger the
situation is the bigger the marketing
budget is right and
when it comes to marketing it's a real
brainwashing process
that people don't understand right
you have seeding companies
so what i mean by seedling is like
you'll be looking up and you'll say
little baby donates 15 000 to the
schools for books
it'll be on a random thing right you
don't understand
it has you thinking about a little baby
little d-dog does 1 million streams or
24 hours if you don't know who lil d-dog
is you're gonna hit that link who the
[ __ ] is this oh oh follow oh that's your
song stream
right so it's a lot of other types of
marketing outside of this putting your
[ __ ] up right just like radio bro you
work radio of course we know what it is
you have mix show
right and you have your ads
then you have your positioning
leading up to your rotation
it's been songs i've hated lil wayne one
of the greatest of all time
i hated lollipop
six weeks seven weeks in the radio two
o'clock in the morning i'm driving up
the freeway
sick of that lollipop
right right because i'm hearing this
[ __ ] so much
mentally
my mind started to like it so what's to
say [ __ ] when it comes to digital
marketing right
it's a whole nother process that happens
for us to highlight an artist and keep
him in front of you and by that
like boosting streams
i mean strength that's streams are
boosted
body you know by doing these things okay
okay okay people follow the number bro
like um let's say for instance i don't
we watch kanye and drake they already
have a fan base right
but every day
you saw
donda
does this many streets yesterday right
right now let's
erase
donda kanye and drake and let's say
it's lil e
right or a true car one of them artists
true car streams two millions 24 hours
right
the people that follow true car that
didn't know that i was there are going
to go and the people that don't know
true car they gonna say who the [ __ ] is
true car let go see what they talking
about
right now money was spent
for these things to be put in front of
you so when you work in 10 15 different
platforms from your you know your
smallest on up right
that happens so that
in turn
drives the stream right not only does it
drive the stream it creates your fan
base that's your ticket sales at your
concerts so what you would do is have a
digital marketing company definitely
that youtube digital you would drop a
bag with and then they they would get
your song on a [ __ ] ton of user curated
playlists that uh not not only that um
even on your youtube side you know you
can run ads right so you can do youtube
ads on one side and then on the on the
screen you've been watching [ __ ] uh
the baby and then somebody saw a person
and i'm watching strictly that [ __ ] i'm
working out video coming on i want to
hear is
right
it's about four songs come on this is
how i discovered rod wave no [ __ ] wow
crazy about rod ray one of my favorite
young rappers he's incredible right i'm
working out and i'm listening to uh you
know uh the baby [ __ ]
and uh
out of nowhere [ __ ] soul come on
now i don't think rod wave just came on
because it came on
that's programming yeah no they went
like that
they did
buys right from that um no i follow rod
wave i stream it's not a day that's went
by in the last year that i haven't
listened to rod rave's music off of
spotify
right and i've since then shared it what
about 100 of my friends and that's my
age and that's how this works [ __ ] with
this youngster now i don't know how many
people did they shared it with and this
how it is works now how many people like
me discovered it
like that right and these are the things
that people just simply don't know about
when people say the machine
at the labels not only is the finance
there but the politics of relationships
there that says when certain labels call
they're going to get a slot
you know what i'm saying
so you know it it it's it's i won't say
it's a controlled thing but
it's definitely a machine it's a
possibility will this happen where
have you seen this happen where there's
a project that's coming out and the
label
drops a bag to boost the streams and i'm
not saying that they're not organic
streams because with a lot of these
digital marketers when you say stream
boosting i mean like it's not that
people coming in and saying it's not
like there's like a all right
we're paying for these streams to be
like this stream boosting comes in like
different forms 10 15 different forms
right
marketing right so
have you seen it where
a label will literally drop a stupid bag
to ensure their album gets to be number
one for the week
well the insurance comes from
first of all understand this
labels no
right you notice
no other artist dropped the weeks of
kanye and drake
true
we know who's dropping
for one
so you don't [ __ ] around with [ __ ] well
kanye dropped sunday at eight a.m but
yeah well you don't [ __ ] around with
[ __ ] like that yeah yeah because now
where you go might wanna spend a hundred
two hundred thousand dollars on the full
digital marketing
campaign right you [ __ ] around some [ __ ]
like kanye that's like you spend twenty
thousand dollars
because
you know what i mean
they just won't work one song they'll
work 15. um
you just stay out of that traffic that
[ __ ] bigger than you right right right
you know what i'm saying you don't
certain people you don't [ __ ] with you
just let them get out the way and you
let it blow over for about
three weeks or a month
then you come in and drop your back so
when i say that to say this if a label
is like all right we got a
we got a marketing budget of a half
million dollars
right
they already know that half a million
dollars they're gonna spend here there
here youtube you know our seed companies
uh radio
you know um [ __ ] like this you ever look
went to spotify
right and uh you go to spotify by the
way for everyone who dm's me every day
you cannot pay to get on my platform
listen anyway you go to spotify and
let's say rap caviar right
call a race picture yep
she's the
yep she's the cover of rap caviar
i don't you don't realize if you're
going to rap caviar just to listen to
the playlist soon you see not your first
thing your mind's gonna say is let me
check out the song
that's what i do to every time someone's
on the cover i go like what let me see
what songs on here from these muffins
you understand now one thing about
spotify they pretty much hand pick who
they want 100 spotify give you a call
like hey we want y'all to you know to be
the cover of this this this and that but
all this [ __ ] right it's things that are
done to kind of because it's been done
time and time again we know we spend
this here here here there
based upon the artist is following now
we can expect this kind of traffic
you know what i'm saying it's just like
lab rat [ __ ] bro they know we get this
[ __ ] this dose this happened
this dose this how it's the same [ __ ] so
when you hear people saying that yeah
you got [ __ ] say well [ __ ] we
gonna spend 3 million they know that 3
million is going to guarantee
organically after they do all exposure
three million should bring us
you know three hundred four hundred
thousand
album sales
they know these things y'all i mean they
gotta figure it out it's got it figured
out that's just what it is last thing i
wanna talk about without getting into
the specifics of the incident um but
really uh obviously one of your artists
blue face got into an altercation
it's all over the internet right now um
i don't want to get into what actually
happened but i do want to get into some
of the
the the things that you were saying
about this before we started the
interview just about like
for any artist who's watching this yeah
you know about staying out of places
where you're not getting it back like
kind of you know obviously you know
blueface is a great dude yeah when you
when you're a artist
um your business
regardless of what your homies say or
what whatever say your business your
everything about you is a business what
you say what you do
you know if he has a car accident it's
not going to be
you know jonathan porter out of carson
he's gonna say blueface the rapper
was involved in the car accident carson
has nothing to do with music but because
it's him he's a business and you're a
target you know in this situation
somebody pulled a weapon out on him i
mean they pulled a knife out on him
man had to defend himself you know what
i mean when things started to happen you
know what i mean when you seeing camera
footage you only seen a part of it part
of it you know what i mean but once
again it's like that's why i urge
rappers to um
keep the proper tools around you that's
going to absorb those things to where
those things happen the wall is around
you to where
they can't really get to you
you know what i mean this is what
security is for i mean you've been that
wall before yeah i'm all i've taken
shout out to stitches
i've taken that hit you know what i mean
i mean that's just me um you know but
unfortunately blueface is young man he
has a life and i think his struggle with
this music thing is
sometimes he wants to be normal
and i'm trying to get him to understand
is you're not normal as much as you want
to be normal
that's the downside to this [ __ ] he's
also an extremely tall good-looking kid
with tattoos so it's it's not a very
inconsis like it like when he goes out
it's like another one of his downfalls
is is he's genuinely a nice guy yes yeah
so he's not an [ __ ] to where if you
walking up on him he gonna be like hey
get the [ __ ] away from you have people
stop you he genuinely is a nice guy he's
going to talk have a conversation which
opens him up to more it's very walking
up he's on some [ __ ] right so what
you don't see is a dude walks up and
then blue light being cool hey how are
you doing yeah and then he like hey [ __ ]
your mama spits out some [ __ ] right now
the artist that's a human being
reacts
now it's oh blueface did this
right and then that's how it go so
that's the pros and cons to this [ __ ]
you know when you when you're that
right you can either be regular and not
have nobody pay any attention to you and
be a hell of a entrepreneur and get your
money
right i've known entrepreneurs at one
point in time shout out to white boy
cole who had more money and everybody in
the [ __ ] club was standing
outside from the supper club couldn't
get in because they didn't know who he
was
you know i mean so when games said
that's my part to bring him in dj holla
all cold sitting the bottles hollow cold
yo this is cold this is cold this is
cold right now his identity gave him
face and people responded to him as if
he was some type of celebrity in our
city right so the same rule applies like
once you get that
light on you
it's what it is you got to move your
recording you got to move accordingly
man it's a gift and a curse it's a gift
and a curse so you got to know that
people do ign look at blueface in this
fight dude running the ring he ran in
the ring holding his phone he went in in
one hand
he knew like i'm doing this because
that's blue face i was closer to him in
blue face but he like [ __ ] the draw the
likes his blue face
so they gonna try
and i think you know he's young
he's full of life he's full of energy
and sometimes he just want to have fun
just normal fun and i think he's
learning that that's the task you signed
up tonight
yeah i mean i think for anybody right
like
you got you can't overexpose yourself
you know like i think like uh even me
like i tell my wife you know i'm like
you know she wants to go walk down
melrose i'm like listen sweetheart like
now ain't the time for us to go walk
down melrose with your wedding ring on
because i'm not gonna be
yeah that's real [ __ ] i'm not gonna
people know
i'm just not gonna be the one like like
at the end of the day like big boy how
many places you see big boy just out
rome 100 and and and that's
you know how many people know who the
[ __ ] is the way i am i'm like yo if i'm
not getting paid a dj i'm not going to
the club you cannot know what big boy
looks like right and the minute he opens
his mouth you know exactly who he is
because he's got you could be at
mcdonald's and not know who this dude is
saying yeah man give me a wiper [ __ ]
hello
hey man aren't you yeah dude get all
excited big boy might be having a bad
day dude hey man grass big boy by the
shoulder big boy those elbows actually
you know big boy assaults taxi dude to
mcdonald's yeah this is why big boy
ain't gonna go in the [ __ ]
mcdonald's he's gonna send somebody else
he gonna go through the drive-through
this is what this is there it is well
look uh we're gonna transition to the
other part of the interview which is an
hour and a half long and gotcha there's
a lot of game in it appreciate you for
pulling out man it's a hunting interview
y'all tuned in and bootleg calves
uh you always have to always have an
open mic here whack no i appreciate it
man you hey kev you know
uh
people don't realize that you can vouch
for this
i think about people when they know i'm
not thinking about them because it was a
few years ago well out of nowhere
you got a call
i'm sitting with they setting up the
real 923 and they going over there djs
i'm like yo y'all need to bring cab to
the city i always tell every i always
tell everybody
right on the phone called me at dinner
at dinner we was at dinner this was in
2014. yeah we was at dinner and i was in
tampa
and whack hits my line hey i'm with doc
winner right now at dinner
they're launching the radio i'm telling
them you're the guy
and i always tell everybody yo wack
really selflessly just threw me the
craziest lob watch this you might hear
from whack every 18 months
i don't do [ __ ] because now i'm gonna uh
you know
work this situation i just genuinely do
[ __ ]
that's a big misconception about you man
is like i think like i always hear
people be like uh you know when they
talk about you and they don't know you i
gotta step in and be like yo whack ain't
that guy like people really think like
you're like a really unreasonable dude
or like you know definitely if you do
something for them you're going to hang
them out like on some suge night [ __ ]
over a balcony i'm like yo whack is a
we'll see one of the smartest smartest
guys in the music
yeah
should never hung anybody over the
balcony so vanilla ice never got hung
over the bathroom okay definitely got
hung over the balcony
but see it's kind of like the kid that
got kicked
and all the teachers seen was a kid
doing the hitting right what people
don't talk about is that little young
black kid
right who did the production for ice ice
baby
oh vanilla ice said [ __ ] you i'm not
gonna give you four or five million
dollars
people don't want to talk about he
went through every
resource he could to get his money
and his [ __ ] wasn't right when he
brought it to suge knight she said sug
i'll give you half the money you can get
my money sugar said young black brother
i don't want half your money i just want
what's reasonably coming to me let me
have my attorneys contact them and
figure it out after eight and nine
months of that not working then he went
through other extremes of getting it
done now watch this
is it
suge knight's fault that he had to go to
that extreme or is it vanilla ice's
fault for totally ignoring it when it
was trying to be handled the corporate
way fair enough
so i you know i just got to defend that
because i know what's really behind that
it wasn't a thing which sure came in and
i ain't want no [ __ ] verse for
vanilla right
the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying and
let the record be shown and do not [ __ ]
with whack either you know what i'm
saying because i've seen the dark side
of whack as well personally me myself yo
listen whack thank you man let's get
into the rest of the interview right now
all right look man special edition the
hundredth episode of the bootleg head
podcast what am honored to monitor
monitor episode 100 we had to do
something special and bring my bro my
big brother man whack 100 for episode
100. yeah definitely welcome back listen
i'm honored there's a whole lot of ways
you could have went
so you know it's an honor to be here
yeah i was like man there was a couple
people i was like we got to get whacked
back episode 100 is only right man we on
the west coast [ __ ] let's do it the way
we suppose welcome back uh first of all
how how has everything been going with
you man because you've been
all over uh every academics post i mean
look shit's been kind of crazy since you
did the podcast you know um
you know it's always a
a backlash
you know when you
go against the grain
you know what i mean so when you know
when you're not
flowing the way everybody else is
flowing
you're gonna get that backlash now the
question is can you stay you got to be
able to stand in the rain can you with
withstand that [ __ ] you were standing
right a lot of people was you know a lot
of people cliquish you know what i mean
and they caught up and you know who
gonna continue to talk to him or not you
know i mean unfortunately a lot of
people that i know and do business with
they've been long-term relationships and
uh they they called me and expressed
what they don't like but the brotherhood
and the you know the comrades [ __ ] is is
it's too deep i even got something that
won't call me you know when they get
over being mad then they'd call me and
they'd tell me what it was but other
than that man you know you got to be a
stat and you got to be your own boss and
you got to know your own route
you got to know what you're doing with
it
you know what i mean and that's what it
is people sit back and because they
don't know what you're doing
assumption when it comes to the
to the human mind they're going to
always assume the worst so you know i'm
since then i think i'm
takashi signed to me six nine this man
is by me uh
[ __ ]
i didn't put him on my neighborhood you
know they come up with all kind of crazy
ass [ __ ] but you know you gotta let them
run wild with it if you understand the
entertainment business because that's
the clickbait that's what keep people
talking about you and hopefully you can
put some in front of the people right to
to further the conversation whack did
this this this oh yeah and
this is coming out this is going on so
you gotta know how to finesse you gotta
know how to work it well i think like we
did an interview probably like four or
five months ago and in that interview
you had said you did not feel like six
nine was a snitch he was a civilian yeah
so you said that way before you had even
had any contact with this dude way
before rolling loud weekend happening i
think the misconception of that is
people saying like
well he was doing what he was doing you
know with the people he was doing it
with and my whole thing is like
those people should have never even had
him involved in those things um you know
it starts with me from the beginning you
know what i mean i'm not gonna take a uh
a a hot rod race car in gold cross
country right i know somewhere in there
you know that ain't built for that it's
going to blow up i'm going to take
something that's standard stock the
cadillac the range rover some [ __ ]
that's built for that
to take that cross-country but then i'm
not gonna take my my cadillac and my
range roll with my honda and try to do a
competing a quarter mile right right
right you know what i'm saying so it's
like my whole way of seeing it is
yeah i see what happened and what went
on but
you know i knew that goddamn hot rod was
gonna blow up before i got to arizona
right
[ __ ] gets three miles to the
gallon it's running lean it's running
hot and i'm trying to go across country
and i'm i'm trying to do 80 on the
freeway it's going to blow overheat yeah
it's going overheat so i feel like you
know i understand why they did it you
know what i mean um you had a few people
that was trying to figure out the music
industry
you know what i mean and and you know
we're dealing with artists bro you got
to know how to move them you got to know
how to finesse them and you got to know
how to bow down to them and let them be
the boss and be the employee to them
yeah i mean it's a it's a tricky game so
you know um
i've always seen the kid day one that's
like it was a gimmick it's a lot of
artists that's a gimmick a lot of dudes
running around with tattoos on their
faces and
walking a certain way they just got real
dudes around them and the real dudes
around them
gives them the persona that they're that
so
a lot of people might i mean i think the
argument is like he he put hits on
people's heads right he put money on
people's heads he paid people to shoot
shoot at people etc
and i think the argument is
once you do something like that you're
you're a criminal technically right like
you you are you've signed off on that
lifestyle definitely so
what do you you know
you can never watch blow
of course i love blow
dude was moving more goddamn cocaine
into la la right
but
deep down inside who was he
i mean yeah he was a just a normal dude
okay when the heat came
what did the normal dude do
what are you supposed to do
right now if i was the guy playing blow
right
unfortunately i'm subject
to the politics
and i've been in these situations i've
been charged with murders
that i know i didn't commit
and all i can say is i plead the fifth
see in court
my homeboy just sitting there
the people that
know it
they know the details behind it they
didn't jump up and say oh no it wasn't
him it was me and you know what they did
what they supposed to do they supposed
to be quiet right this is a better
situation if they putting the body on
somebody that we all know didn't do it i
got a better chance of being in them
right but i'm gonna sit down i'm gonna
spend some money but this is what comes
with it i'm you know i'm born and bred
and i'm into this [ __ ] i'm initiated
into this right and and
everybody no matter what bro me and you
right now could go to
the marines training camp that don't
necessarily mean we gonna become a
marine
you have to pass things and go through
stages of things for them to say
you are now
that
they can't do so we're here for marine i
put him on the chopper send his ass to
afghanistan you mean he might have a gun
in his hand he might bust some shots in
the right direction
my [ __ ] and detonate the whole
[ __ ] battalion because we don't
know what we doing with this grenada we
don't know how to move so you know
no matter what
they tried to paint him to be
right you give a 12 year old the keys to
a lamborghini he gonna get in that
[ __ ] man and he ain't gonna
drive her like a lamborghini [ __ ] i can
drive this
i barely know how to drive folks but i
know how to drive by my school
might run up on the curb run into this
machete no telling what he gonna do when
he come back you're gonna say yo you
drove the lamborghini like this he
didn't see it was a kid that's driving a
car that's all he's seen that wasn't
supposed to be driving
so you tell a dude like this
we gonna do whatever you tell us to do
he's already intrigued by the streets
right right right
right right
so in his head he like
one side of him is like damn they gonna
i can tell him what to do
the other side is
you know i'm a colleague cocking [ __ ] it
okay
do this
oh [ __ ]
do that oh [ __ ]
so then you got people saying
well
because he was telling them these things
that makes them bad
so
let's get a few of the misconceptions
out the way obviously you're not working
you're not getting any money with six
nine outside of maybe a fight with
blueface if that's not a fight with
blueface shut up woody so that's gonna
happen and then and that's the whole
thing right is that
to me
right
the streets in the music industry uh
they're not the same
people in the music industry talk about
the streets
if that dude that was doing the talking
about the streets really did those
things his ass would be in the
penitentiary be incriminating himself
right because most of the people who are
actually doing that as you've seen over
the last couple of years they've they
got rico charges so garlico charges
quick i mean who scheisse is sitting
down right now one of the hardest
rappers in the world yeah shout out to
nephew too good dude good youngster man
send my respects to his father and his
family but um
so i've never personally seen
the exacts on the 50th floor
say listen today
we're gonna determine if if a little
d-dog get put on the hood
i've never seen that conversation on the
50th floor
right
and i've also seen them say
you two dirty in them streets that come
to the 50th floor
right
so street business or street politics is
just that right that's what it is
you catch me trying to take uh six nine
to somebody neighborhood shoot a video
uh you know uh
some crazy [ __ ] like that i'm in total
violation right i would never even bring
my homeboys who will follow me into the
fire
around that because that's not that's
not their thing they they're not part of
the business they'll be there with me
right so whatever it is i did choose to
do with him that's why nobody with me
with my wife and kids which i said day
one you know my daughter's a fan that's
what that is you know she don't give a
[ __ ] about none of that of course right
um
but if i got an attorney on the 50th
floor and he got my email and i got his
email and there's email attached to him
an attorney says hey i see this this is
available or just something that he may
want to do and my attorney's talking to
me
and this business i'm definitely going
to conduct that business
i'm not the guy to say
[ __ ] 6'9 i want to see him starve to
death i want to see him die today and
never make another dime
i can say that that's not realistic
he's what he represents to his fans is
bigger than me
i'm not his fan base so what's driving
his revenue is gonna continue to drive
his revenue whether what we think about
it or not it don't matter you know what
i'm saying right so i'm i'm a
businessman right i'm def i've done
business with
jewish people
gay people
crips
you know what i'm saying i mean i've
done business with all kinds of [ __ ]
that may not like me
one of my head plumbers who gave me a 20
discount was a nazi type dude i could
tell i had the big big red real redneck
dude right but you know that was that
was who he was it had nothing to do with
the service i needed
you know what i'm saying so
i'm never i'm always been the wolf in my
world bro since a kid you know i mean if
i see it my way and i see a different
way or a different lane
i'ma follow my lane if i crash and burn
following my lane right i can live with
that
but if i crash and burn or starve to
death
following somebody else's lane i can't
live with that
that's fair so
you're let me ask you this because i
think everyone respects you and your
acumen as a businessman in the music
industry right
i think you're one of the most brilliant
minds in the game you know i always say
like you there's a lot of misconceptions
about you as a person
um would you like obviously
you're from pacoima
you're you know your your
reputation in the streets
speaks for itself right
at this point in time in your life
do you put the business first or being a
piru first
uh
pararoo is first when they come to paru
business okay
right break that down cause i think some
people might look well it is okay this
is what it is you got some people that's
from a neighborhood and they're gonna be
they're gonna do what they told to do
okay no matter what they want to do
then you got some people who do the
dictating on what's being told to do
some people that politic at the table
was being told to do
um
my neighborhood
hasn't uh those are not my streets
right
that's where i'm from
right let's get this right
when they were my streets i woke up
every day that's where i got my money
that's where i protected the blocks
every day yep that's why i did my dirt
had my fun my partying was right there
like a hamster
on those streets
right it's a whole nother team over
there that that state streets right i
don't uh
dictate or override what they choose to
do those streets are being managed
totally different today
than they were my heyday right right
things have changed you know
we glorified
selling dope getting the money a lot of
them grow up high how much dope they use
today you know who am i to judge that's
a thing
you know what i'm saying we sagged our
parents down our [ __ ] ankles
they just wear them tighter
you know that's a thing right so
par root business
it's just that
six nine never mixes with that he
shouldn't have been mixed with that in
the beginning when they was doing what
they was doing out there that shouldn't
have never happened i took offense to
him running around with the rainbow hair
and the red bandanna
that's something that i would never
practice that something you would have
never co-signed if it was someone coming
out of l.a it wouldn't happen right it's
not gonna happen either you that or
you're not you know what i'm saying um
my
family business
is just that my business is just that i
mean because if i was on some real paroo
street [ __ ]
i wouldn't sign blueface
fair enough right
it's real politics behind me signing
blue faces deeper than people know
outside of cripping blood [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
you know that
maybe some of them don't knows a few of
mines don't know
right so if i was like awesome
if paru dictated everything you did in
life on the music side then you wouldn't
even be [ __ ] with blue face
yeah it can't happen at the end of the
day snoop dogg wouldn't have been a
death row
norwood dies or corrupt nate dog fair
enough but we all run around with the
death row shirts and that [ __ ] was
really was built on the talents and
skills of cripism mm-hmm and and and uh
and the business and the politics of
some pyro [ __ ] yeah so um
we've established that right so you know
obviously
with the six nine thing i feel like
there's bit like we had glasses malone
up here right and glasses spoke
glasses did not speak towards you in any
sort of funny way right glass is gonna
totally disagree what i'm doing one
million percent that's my nephew i know
what he's gonna glass is like i think he
he's gonna see it
you gotta understand glasses look at me
like
[ __ ] that's one our west coast generals
right
but it's not the general
that's conducting that business
you understand what i'm saying yeah it's
just like
i'm not whacked from parou when i'm
being dad to my kids and you're not
whacked from pyro when you're running
100 entertainment and definitely not and
looking for new talent i had i had bro
listen i caught so much flack
behind blueface the famous [ __ ] who had
a song out called respect my crippling
right
right
now if i would allow
all that those powers to be to dictate
my ability it's a reason why i
transitioned
out of doing business in the streets of
doing business in the building i
realized a long time it's only
profitable for so long you get a
two-year run 18-month run three
five-year run you know what i mean uh
look at bmf for one you know these dudes
making a lot of money but you know
they've been going you know uh 20 years
almost you know 15 20 right so it's kind
of like
you know i feel like
slow and steady runs the race with me
you know the the long long more the
longevity the more longevity you had at
doing something the most successful
chance of being successful at it you
know what i mean so
i i don't expect everybody glasses says
he's just moving into the lane of being
an exec you know he got an artist or two
now right you know he came to see me you
know i mean a couple weeks ago figure
out a few things right he's moving into
that and he's gonna cross those those
thresholds where it comes to some things
that
you know he wasn't supposed to mac 10
believe it or not caught some flack
over signing g malone
i don't i don't doubt that yeah
englewood blood queen street it's a
bunch of robbers in in the wood like
hold on man you could've did that well
he he uh he equated 69 to being worse
than hitler
he said he is an evil demonic man who's
worse than hitler
i wouldn't say he's worse than hitler
because of casualty
between the holocaust and uh i'm just
saying what he did
yeah 89
89 individuals who's laying down you
know you know and a lot of people got to
understand you know i kind of did a
little research on a few things and i
ain't justifying nothing at 69d and i
think also i think people think that you
are but if you actually watch the
interview
she didn't justify anything i'm not
justified nothing he did i was really
trying to really get him to understand
what he wasn't what he'd never been you
know when it came to that um but i think
there is a slight misconception right
um six nine did not send anybody to
prison
he said nobody to prison
what he did was saved himself from going
to prison
right because
everybody already was indictment was
indicted they were all a part of the
same ricoh case they were all indicted
already
uh ninety percent of them if you really
gonna read their paperwork wright was
violating the street code [ __ ] right
on their phone
saying things on their phone doing
things on that phone they weren't
supposed to do so whether six nine
did what he did or not they were still
going to the penitentiary right so it
wasn't like they arrested him and then
they didn't know about everybody else
and he like nah this dude this dude this
dude and they released him and he wore a
wiretap to you know
to gliding this dude up this dude up all
y'all had y'all warrants all y'all got
pretty much arrested by the same time
you know what i mean when he went on a
breakfast club they all knew what was
coming he was trying to you could tell
the way he was trying to disassociate he
knew it was coming but it was it was
already too late you know what i mean um
i think they only went and picked
everybody up because the wire taps that
he had something going on in connecticut
and they heard on the wiretap that they
was gonna push up on him in connecticut
that's when they like okay we're not
gonna jeopardize this it's time to pick
everybody up right so they was going
regardless right brother this man he
could have went in there and kept it
gangsta and said [ __ ] that i ain't
saying nothing he would have just been
in there with him
nobody was getting out right uh
everybody pretty much lined theyself up
on the phone on the wiretaps on the wire
taps
and we've heard some of the leaked
conversations and some of those wiretaps
you know was were not in favor
of six nine it was some of those cases
they got it was crimes that committed
against him so you know whatever they
had coming it was coming to them anyway
based upon whatever they was doing right
right the evidence they already had yeah
right so
they was going anywhere they was running
the [ __ ] up ship you know it was a
sinking ship and that's what it was what
he did
was what i expected the guy from blow to
do
he turned back to who he really was
straight up and that's why my people
that's around me
right those people that went to the
military and got trained that's what
they kidnapped their [ __ ] they
sitting there torturing their
[ __ ] what they trained to do
say they [ __ ] name and they
rank and they in a number
that's it now you take a [ __ ]
they ain't been trained for that and
skilled for that that's why some people
are just this some people navy seals
some people green beret right it's a
different thing they're not going to
send the death dude to send the marines
out to do the green beret job right they
know if he get caught he's gone oh yeah
the office over here and such is over
here and the generals over here right so
they send the green beret dudes in there
because that's a different type of
training burst physical physically
mentally and psychologically
right because if they get caught
they train to die with it die about it
uh there's nothing about takashi
that tells you that he's
gonna be able to withstand that pressure
it's not gonna happen the pressure's
strong i even had some some real
gangsters
crack
you know i tell people what a dude is
willing to accept that
25
he may not be willing to accept that 45.
you know [ __ ] go find out where
they are mabel living backwoods alabama
quick
man
we got 30 years for you man
because he'd rather deal with it like
that free
then sit
in that penitentiary
but keeping it real
while he watch others
go [ __ ] his baby mama um
yeah the baby mama's moving on you know
what i'm saying
go hit his spot somebody this is just
real [ __ ] right somebody's gonna end up
raising his kids
so
and i tell people this this is why you
know um
a lot of my soldiers
right the older they get
the less involved i make sure they are
when it comes to that kind of thing
right
you know i try to move them into being
professional businessman
not to say that they are crack but i
don't want to even put them in a
position or a situation where they got
to even think about it but i ain't got
to think about that yeah it appeared i
mean i understand it
because at the end of the day
you don't ever want to you know i feel
like
when you get yourself involved in that
it's not probably out of choice it's out
of environment it's out of necessity and
the goal is having fun with something
that that's not funny what i'm saying is
like the goal is though like obviously
if you
the goal would be to evolve and
and get out of that eventually right bro
listen i'ma tell you right now my goal
for the last three years has been to
not even be on the west coast at least
three to four months out of the year
you'll be in china working on [ __ ]
you'll be helping me all over the place
i'm buy a coaster i live on these coasts
when i want to
right so that's now my goal is to i only
want to be here six months out the year
you know i want to spend two months
overseas conducting business i you know
what i mean and then i can spend another
month vacation in another three months
just other places where i need to be
i don't
i don't want to run the hood i want to
position myself to come back
and control the hood by means of real
estate
businesses
you know my ultimate goal guidance my
ultimate goal is to come back and buy my
projects
that's i've been a goal of mine is to
come back and actually purchase my
projects and i can't get that done in
the hood because whatever i can do in
the hood all i would have to do on the
hood it's going to hinder me from having
the proper documents paperwork and cash
flow to go do that right you know what
i'm saying i got to come back
a business i got to come back a mogul to
do that yeah you know what i'm saying so
and i'm not knocking what i want to be
is is
to those in my neighborhood who who not
being brainwashed by those that's my age
and older than me and salty and mad
because they didn't find their way out
say they'll look we know this dude was
this this this did tom put in work did
all the crazy [ __ ] and all that and he
was able to turn it around and do that
do that i got a ged from central
juvenile hall if i'm able to do it it
ain't nobody in my neighborhood is not
able to do it right i just i didn't i
didn't uh my hundred percent of my
success is not music and i don't think
my my biggest success is gonna be music
because really i look down on myself for
doing what i do in music because i'm
still dependent on another man
i wake up in one of my artists and did
some crazy [ __ ] you know this [ __ ] and
this [ __ ] it it affects the business me
and you know you can't just birth for
artists overnight you got to start back
over and rebuild
and any businessman know at that point
in time the revenue gonna change so you
got to downsize and you got to do things
a little different that's where the
diaper company comes from me challenging
myself to do something outside of this
that can create another type of wealth
and then you're only depending on
yourself and your team as opposed to
because you know it is on me artists are
very they're variables right you deal
with artists maybe they have a bad day
maybe you know yeah you know you know a
lot of my real business partners you
know it's like people from the naacp you
know people that that run financial
institutions you know uh
80 of my time on the phone is with them
right
i'm not talking to the homies
that's a text you straight you're
straight you're good you're good great
you know what i'm saying other than that
that's what that is hey what up man we
got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview let me ask you this whack um
i think people
first of all i love when you
share your thoughts online because i
feel like they're genuine yeah and and
you're very very like
you know like you said you don't say the
[ __ ] people think i'm scared to say so
but but there's so let me ask you this
right
why
there's people who will be like yo why
is whack online so much like you'll be
on clubhouse going crazy on clubhouse
clubhouse shout out to my my nephew
rocky rockwood family ninety second
street as he would say so he's got a
room no so just give me like like no way
i'm gonna give it to you go ahead okay
my little homeboy had a room
right and he like man i'm trying to get
my room popping
right
so i'm like all right i had to
understand club i really know this [ __ ]
but i'm coming see what it is i'm like
all right cool so when i did the six
nine interview right i tell nephew
listen won't you go on vacation for a
minute and put me with the people so i
can set up the room he like what you
mean i said i need you to go on vacation
because he you know young [ __ ] real
blood you know what i'm saying he all
mixed with that [ __ ] he he just in the
room as rocky from eaglewood family
so by the time he spent off or do what
he do i come in and
bring the kid in to host the room
his room go from 13 000 to 30 000
overnight
thank you they don't come in and say
give me half of the room i want to own
the room right right i passed the room
back to nephew he has some things to say
to me he like damn look you could have
told me what you was gonna do man i
might not have been with it i said
listen you see where your room is at
right yeah i took the hit i'm about to
take the backlash for it i take that
room and go generate you some revenue
right right he loved me today for it he
didn't agree
right but you know um and then clubhouse
is a fun space when you're bored ain't
got nothing to do you better went to
sleep early in the day six o'clock got
up at
six to midnight you get up everybody
else sleep stay up on clubhouse right
clubhouse
i also feel like you low-key kind of
resurrected clubhouse because i
definitely did that's what they did bro
i'm like i didn't even know people were
still on clubhouse until i'm like yo
whack's going crazy with me
i reinstalled the app
i literally but but let me ask you this
right so like the six nine thing happens
and so much fallout as far as
relationships with you and
artists who people might perceive you to
be close with like obviously uh there
was a jim jones french shoot that you
pulled up too early last like last year
and then the jim jones thing happens um
where you know well you know i got to
blame for something had nothing to do
with me
because they say i provided the platform
for um
for him for six nine to say what he said
right but i'm a key with gangsta i don't
i don't harbor fugitives
you know i'm saying i got a lot of
people that i've grow with
knew 15 20 30 years and then you know
somebody slipped me some paperwork
you know what i'm saying
based upon what i'm reading and what i'm
seeing not to say i've seen paperwork on
jim i just heard the recordings of me
understanding the law
i'm a little confused and
one-sided with that because i know what
that is you know what i'm saying so and
you didn't necessarily bring up your
skepticism about that situation until
there was static brought to you yeah
well you know he he he had wanted to
bring it up during the interview
but i didn't know nothing about what he
was talking about i'm like yo you can't
talk about jim doing his interview
because because i don't know what you're
talking about
yeah you know what i'm saying so he he
was so adamant about wanting to show me
what he was talking about
it's scary i did some buster [ __ ]
because
i was good with jim at the time right
and i didn't even let him show it to me
because if he show me something
that's real
then i gotta let him talk about it
right so i didn't want that to happen on
that on that right so that's why if you
look at that like that never came up in
that interview right he tried to show me
something on on on casanova right which
he had on his phone so me and casanova
relationship is kind of like we see each
other one day it's cool another day we
may not say nothing to each other and i
know he in the situation he in and i
don't like to kick no man when they down
so i didn't even entertain what he was
trying to show me because casanova ain't
here to defend himself so that's why i
didn't allow that to be talked about you
know i mean you know so it's kind of
like
i don't know where me and novak you know
i mean i think we both respect each
other as men but then we we got our
little issues with each other about
whatever it may be right right so
that's why i didn't allow that to happen
but you know when they come on clubhouse
and you know he was on i got tired of
people asking me
about yo six nine is so you know what
i'm gonna bring him on there y'all
asking and what shocked the [ __ ] out of
me is the people that will come super
aggressive at me about six nine
questions no clubhouse
man uh well yeah six nine sir excuse me
man they didn't have the same energy
asking
yeah [ __ ] me up right now i'm one person
bro i'm one person and i'm going to
defend myself when i say about giving
him a platform
right i want everybody to see this
if you people really felt the way you
feel about this individual right it
should have said
whack 100 invites
six not in the clubhouse only eight
people showed up
it should not say that damn near 14 000
people came through there to a point
that the clubhouse staff they [ __ ]
expanded they banned with because it's
seven eight thousand people coming in
there at a time and another four five
thousand people waiting to get in there
i didn't give him the platform the
people that came in there
to hear that man speak
gave him the platform
right if it was if it's that bad with
him
why support him
the venue should be empty right
we've all seen an empty venue
so i think people might be like why you
did the interview obviously there's
there's the blue face fight that is that
gonna happen definitely gonna happen i'm
about
about
6.5 million away from the mark the
number i need
which is easy the runtime once you get
the money going
it's easier to pull other people we'll
get to the fight and and all that but
but but then people might say okay well
look we get it you did you did you but
but why continue to kind of
bring him into
your world like well you know he's not
in my world i don't even see in your
world like let's say like the club like
the club one time you've seen him one
time when i did the interview
how often do you talk to six nine he
called me probably about two three times
a week
so would you say at this point in time
here text me on your facetime and let me
know that you know he got something
because his business going would you say
at this point in time you guys are
friendly with each other
well um i'm not saying you guys are
friends
i don't have i'm not looking to do
nothing to him i was looking to do
something to him i would have been done
i wouldn't have never sat out and did
the interview i feel like it ain't my
job to do nothing to him you know i mean
i i mean at one point in time that used
to be the politics that went his own
like that was somebody's own like that
but you know i come to realize that
people selectively politic what they
want to do when they want to do it and
who they want to do it with oh you know
unless you my direct comrade you know
what i mean you my direct comrade
it don't work like that with me
you know what i'm saying because i look
up all the time and in video shoots and
all kinds of [ __ ] and
people going live and i'm like damn dude
really in there with dude he was just at
the studio we was having a discussion
but you know okay well that's the way
it's curbed is cool
the selective politicking i feel like is
definitely something that um that that
that did have some merit when 69 was
bringing that up in the interview
because there are
i mean i'm not gonna say any names but
there are artists
there are executives that
that i mean
some of the artists right like some big
guys right that yeah um
you know
all but pretty much you can confirm if
probably and goddamn you know something
you know there's some [ __ ] that used
to be
uh uh
crips there's bloods there's probably
some dudes used to be bloods it's crips
you know it's all kind of [ __ ] and
people know about it but because of
whatever's going on with the business
they kind of overlook it well also too i
think like the reason why people are so
the six nine thing was such a huge story
it was like
it's only a huge story let's keep it
real
the story was only huge
because of his platform who he is
right
people can say what they want
anything seen around his name people go
crazy about
y'all giving that power not me
you know what i'm saying
um
i don't i can't i can't recite the six
nine verse
i can't you know what i'm saying i would
have to go to the spotify and see maybe
one song i heard right mistakenly i was
like yo that [ __ ] hard as a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like i couldn't
front you know [ __ ] hard all right
that's him i get it but you know at the
end of the day is you know um
the people that really
have a lot to say about him
don't matter
we're not part of his success as an
artist
we're not the ones going to his concerts
we're not going to buy his merch whether
he told or not
right
yeah we wouldn't have brought his money
either way we wouldn't have brought we
ain't streaming his music you're not his
audience either we're not his audience
so a lot of people that's doing a lot of
talking it really don't matter like you
know what i'm saying you're kind of
wasting your time because his fan base
they don't care do you feel like you see
his engagement the boy put up some bush
you know
no it's crazy it's crazy 15 million do
you feel like do you feel like like
doing that interview did it cost you
anything
um i'm pretty sure it cost me
a few friends um
i'm really not bothered by a lot of
people because i'm really a loner type
dude um my close friends have called me
and got on me i think the one that then
got on me the most right it's birdman
yeah you know i you know i'm gonna do to
keep it 100. you know ain't nobody
bigger than the politics that's my
brother and we get on each other but
birdman out of everybody
birdman had got on my ass like
on me he didn't told me how
dissatisfied he is i love you you my
brother i ain't never going against you
you know that we didn't been in the
trenches together
but god damn it just the way i feel what
did he say
no he just told me he said who you are
and what you stand for and what you
represent is greater than bigger than
that
right so you know at the end of the day
some people got that lane with me you
know i mean where they can call me and
i'm i'm i'm gonna humble myself and i'm
gonna listen you know what i'm saying
because i got that respect for them they
they earned that from me you know what i
mean i got a few of my brothers i ain't
heard nothing from
you know what i'm saying and he's i hear
something from but maybe i won't you
know what i mean but um
i know what my mission and my goal is
and what i'm doing people are going to
take it and they're going to paint the
perception that they want to paint
around it
right there's some people that i feel
like [ __ ] going on with that
i feel like others shouldn't [ __ ] with
mm-hmm
right
t.i for what
you know till they figure that out you
know i ain't with that kind of [ __ ] are
you talking about the allegations about
straight up like with the women yeah and
then it's gonna be interesting to see
that what comes of this you know i mean
me personally i can't front i know t.i
i'm a t.i fan listening to tr music
right i hope he's innocent of this [ __ ]
but i hope i really really hope
that he's innocent of that
right
but there's some things that they went
on in this man's life that a lot of
people didn't overlook too
keeping it real
[ __ ] ain't crazy
it's a lot of [ __ ] been to the
feds [ __ ] understand that 12
months a day kick out
you know what i'm saying you know and
things are done differently these days
so it's like you know it's a lot of
things that they went on that i look at
certain people and say but i understand
it right you know it may be out of
genuine love as a brother maybe some
business going on it may be that they
see it different than me
right you know and vice versa so i'm
gonna understand
my side of it too as well
you know what i'm saying i think like
you said like with the select with the
selective politic and there's a lot of
that you know
at the end of the day like i've done it
i've i've i've done it like i didn't ask
my artists do some [ __ ] they did wrong
on
they're my artist
you know what
what the [ __ ] what's an example of
something like that happening
it's kind of dude um
blueface
right i've got calls in his videos
to where his homeboys was disrespecting
with hand signs
right i got
30 40 year history with some of these
neighborhoods
you know what i'm saying you know they
do [ __ ] so fast these days i didn't
catch it
you know what i mean i'm paying
attention to the artists to the music to
the
attention of what he's saying yeah what
he's doing i really ain't catching
you know what everybody else is doing
right but they like you know a whack
that's your artist on your watch your
[ __ ] video you putting it out
and it's this and it's this and it's
that
right
[ __ ] dude
you know what i'm saying
nah i can't ain't no [ __ ] dude right
because you know outside of
me doing business with this man i've
learned to love this man genuinely i
feel like you and your wife kind of took
him in as like your own man like i mean
i mean you know he has he has a mother
he has a very level no i just mean just
in terms of like just just i remember
when we first met him your wife was
telling us how like you guys were
helping him just get situated with his
first home purchase at the time no it's
hard purchased it's credit it's
life insurance it's medical it's dental
everything and i believe that young man
is going to grow to be something great
outside of music right because he got a
great mind and he said he's he's a good
kid man yeah you know i mean young so he
got he gonna do he's still right now he
tell your ear take the [ __ ] out of me
some shitty dude all right and i'm
pretty sure he hey he know when he see
that phone ringing one in the morning
he already know but i think he know that
ain't to control him that i want to see
him better i want to see him be here you
know what i'm saying because a little
young man you know he got the heart of a
line and he ain't scared of nothing but
you know some things i'm telling him the
bigger you you get you know what i mean
the the the less leeway you had to make
mistakes
he gonna be great he gonna be greater
than what he's doing in music one day
you know he's a businessman his
restaurant that's something he set out
and did i even know he was doing it till
he told me he had fire
set out and did and put it together you
know what i mean so that let me know
here young boss and i'ma respect him as
that but because of my relationship and
my bond with him right
yeah i i i probably when it came to this
crippling blood thing i was probably
supposed to be a little more assertive
or aggressive of what my people was
calling me about right right but the
selected politician because who he was
to me i probably dealt with it a little
wider than you than you would have yeah
you know what i'm saying you know and
with this gang culture we got man it's
so many it was out here this you know we
crips and we got bloods it's our
brothers and families and we bloods and
we got crips that's our relatives people
we didn't did time with all of us got
some type of hatred and then some type
of love and respect for the same side
for the same enemy you know what i mean
so it's a little different um what did
you and 21 savage ever have any dialogue
after the uh
very very
very loud back and forth where you
pretty much are like looking so it's on
site
i'm glad you brought that up because i
wasn't thinking about it like birdman's
been on my ass about 21 savage almost to
a point where i'm damn near jealous man
he ain't whack that's family man
savage family man
you a g
so what if he stepped out of line a
little bit
you know he family you didn't told me
you [ __ ] with him i told you i love the
little [ __ ] to death you supposed to
swallow that and dealt with that
different like he he he another one bird
many been on my ass about but me and
savage spoke the same day
um after the fact i think what it was
was somebody
somebody already told me savage
had a distaste for something i did and i
wasn't tripping so when they pinged him
to the room they told me he was down
there i'm like yo bring him up
so i'm on the impression i'm just gonna
ask him yo savage what's the issue he
gonna tell me and we're gonna have a
conversation because we both have mutual
respect for one another right but you
know he kind of told me somebody fed him
some other [ __ ]
you know what i mean to where when he
came into the room he was already
on charge because he was thinking
something totally different so you know
yeah so which triggered him off a little
[ __ ] look gangster you know a little
punk so you know he figures somebody's
saying this is saying these things about
him he's coming in the room he's dealing
with the [ __ ] head on right i get an
understanding now so we had a
conversation in uh one of his rooms i
mean where we chopped it up people was
in a room this was after the uh
the very loud the one that they went
viral might have been a couple hours
later because listen for people who
don't know you you have when you are
activated no listen i am like like you
know i i
this
businessman
father
uh
but when your fuse is gone i mean i i
know how to do that right
doing that is more
common for me more natural to me yeah
than being this other dude you know what
i'm saying no matter you know with age
it don't do nothing but make you a more
grouchy a dog right right you know what
i'm saying that's all it does so you
know when it happened
because of who it was i think i did
great and that was probably due to my my
my my my wife are you telling me that i
need to learn how to you know deal with
my anger and not snap and have a short
fuse that's why i kind of like was
trying to deal with it but he just kept
coming and then you know it's always
this little man on my shoulder i can't
get rid of this [ __ ] man he
always
trying to tell me and remind me of some
[ __ ] i should be mad at and how i should
be reacting you know when i'm trying to
keep her focus my like this dude don't
go nowhere i i don't i want to get rid
of him but then again i don't because
he's kept me alive
back don't go down that block you know
what you got to do get off handle your
business get up out of there right this
he's part of my instincts you know i
mean so that's why when i when i when i
did talk to savage a couple hours later
he came out and said listen man you know
i thought this and thought that so the
way i came i might have came wrong and i
knew for him to say that after i had
approached him the way i did and we
approached each other i knew it was
genuine and it was some grown man [ __ ]
and he really was outclassing me at that
point in time for me to keep tripping so
i had to hear him out so we you know we
verbally talked and verbally was cordial
for like another 20 30 minutes towards
each other let me ask you this right
because i know that you had kind of um
you know you've obviously evolved as a
man right yeah yeah from being uh
in your younger days definitely and i
think that
there's a argument that someone like
maybe meek mill who who who you know
i know that you know you had kind of
said like look once you state that this
is what it is
then when when you're presented with the
opportunity you gotta you gotta keep
that energy i'll be real with you right
i think something gonna come good out of
the meek mill situation
what do you mean
because
i don't think he's gonna ever do that
again
essentially he's never going to step out
online again because i don't think he's
ever gonna voice what he's gonna do when
he sees somebody
right
um i think he's gonna handle that
differently i think if that's his
thoughts he might keep that to himself
if he gonna do it he's gonna do it but i
think he's gonna put himself in the
position to where
the light ain't on him to do it well
that's what i was going to say about
like the truth i wouldn't have said that
nobody was going to say nothing
what was going to say about the 21
savage thing is like obviously even if
he saw six nine at the club
like he didn't know he did not but but
i'm saying like hypothetically you you
know
he's got his it wasn't his
well see
he's not had all kind of [ __ ] that he
was saying savages said it did so that
was his whole thing his whole thing if
you're one of those dudes saying you're
going to do something to me he don't
care about it saying [ __ ] it now
you're a rat you know he don't give a
[ __ ] about that but if you want him
dudes are saying when i see you it's on
then he sees you and nothing happens
that's his hope yeah i would just i
would hope 21 savage wouldn't risk his
freedom his
his career
just because
you know well i mean i defended 21 in
the interview in the interview you did
because i would like just because y'all
in the same business that doesn't mean
he saw him he saw you and then at the
same token
uh
he ain't the one got the real direct
beat with you so he ought to [ __ ] you
why would he why would he put his [ __ ]
on his own
you know what i'm saying at the end of
the day you know what i mean so i said
let's listen if he did say or do these
things because i hadn't heard it or seen
it personally then i feel where you're
coming from and i think that's what
savage had a problem with you know i
mean but once we talked and he kind of
you know he got it like i got where he
was coming from i don't expect 21 to be
under
not at all have you given uh six nine
any
off camera off clubhouse advice because
if i feel like i told him we should stop
disrespecting the dead
you know i told him that
you didn't made enough enemies
once you give some of that attention to
your fans
i i i don't think that
you need to be so uh controversial
on the negative side
to
bring attention to your music i think
it's
i've seen him do things you know like
over the years but i don't even know who
he was and i've seen him like go visit
uh
go and visit uh
uh
kids you know what i mean that on their
last leg of living and stuff like that
right like you know if you're gonna do
something man focus on your music and do
some positive things man you know your
fans let your fans love you people
that's gonna hate you that's gonna hate
you you've done what you did there's no
sense in uh antagonizing them anymore
you know especially the little dirk [ __ ]
you know i like little dirk yeah the
dirk [ __ ] i feel like he's out of pocket
no i like i like little dirt you know
what i mean so you know i think dirk had
made a verse or something on some drake
song you know i don't know or some [ __ ]
but so what it's a verse you know what i
mean what the [ __ ] you know i mean i i i
like little dirt you know what i mean so
um
you know anybody tied a little dirt you
know he needs to refrain from saying the
things he's been saying you know this
that's what i told him you know what i
mean so whether he does it looked at me
like he might be doing it but you never
know i mean he knows his own man when he
you know i think advertising i'm moving
around with no security now probably not
the smartest idea yeah i think his whole
thing was that is because
i hate to say it he really trying to
expose the streets
because the streets is painting the
picture of those in the streets that's
saying what they want to do that
i can't do because it is you know what
i'm saying so he's like yo bro stop
lying i'm not moving like that i'm right
here so that was his way of kind of like
exposing do you think instead of really
exposing the streets he really just
exposed
the perception of
what hip-hop hip-hop fans think is the
streets right because we look at this
definitely our favorite artist and we
think
yo that's the streets
a lot of people a lot of fans nobody
i seen rick ross uh i was on instagram
and
rick ross was they was uh he was
interviewing it might have been
breakfast club yeah and they asked rick
ross about the drake kanye thing yeah
said madame dude's got too much money
i think i want to see
i want to see them do a song together
ross thing y'all they got too much money
they're having fun with it right right
right right but you know to the fans you
know they eating that [ __ ] up you know
they mean they think drake gonna come
from some gangsters from the six right
and kanye gonna come for some some gds
[ __ ]
from chicago but that's not gonna happen
these dudes
these dudes can't control
they always know when kanye's a
billionaire one of the others gonna be
in the bill where they are
their situation says they can be in the
building that's gonna be asexual that's
gonna be they section you know what i
mean so you know uh
i hate to say it but the world we live
in social media um
they crave negativity
you put up
uh something you're doing something
positive whatever i like i i feel like
uh what's the brother
traitor truth should get
millions of likes and views of course
man he's one of the realities so much
for his community for his community
relief games some relief gains yep
relief gang with him and mr rogers right
you see he get his he get it as little
perks because a lot of people with blue
checks might be on there right but i
think
what traitor truth does
deserves the millions of you i feel like
traitor truth should have 40 million
followers facts right yeah
but then you go over here to the other
dude
right
that got less followers but he may
promote a fight or say yo [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that or this this and that and that's
where all the traffic goes unfortunately
that's the world we live in that's what
it is and i understand that i understand
that to be entertainment
a lot of these people take this [ __ ] too
seriously too real that's like the news
if you think about the news the ratings
for the news were the highest when trump
was in office straight up because
they they want the controversy this dude
the controversy gonna say some crazy
he's gonna say some wild [ __ ] every day
new cnn twitter instagram
and then and and and whether you're on
the left or the right or in the middle
there's a channel for you to go and
there it goes reaffirm what you feel and
there you go a lot of this
a lot of this [ __ ] be entertainment you
know what i'm saying a lot of it is
entertainment because we know we have to
entertain you know what i mean we know
what what what what they want to see
what they don't want do you look at
yourself as an entertainer now kind of
because you're kind of a social media
you know people i think i think my i
think my entertainment kicks in
because the things i say and address
is borderline with the negativity
that might lead to violence
so it's something for them to talk about
because i think that you are looked at
like
for people who don't even know the [ __ ]
you are as far as what you do in the
industry
people just fought like there's people
who were following you just because they
saw some wild [ __ ] you might have seen
yeah exactly they don't maybe respect or
understand they see me i have a fight i
didn't want to have a [ __ ] fight i'm
telling the world i didn't want to have
a fight i didn't go to the burger stand
that day i had to fight
it's a fight that just happened i didn't
[ __ ] record the fight there's just
somebody out there with a goddamn camera
right recording something dead went
right but
that thing got a hundred two hundred
thousand guys that wasn't crazy and it's
not even the first time you've knocked
someone out on camera shout out to
stitches
i had a million fights right right right
because they saw it then that's just
what that is right but that's what the
people want that's what they crave i
don't i why i will sit and watch a chick
film with my wife because that's my wife
right
man put on some [ __ ] with them dudes
jumping out the helicopter this [ __ ]
just got bombed the drones came in look
that's what i want to see right that's
what excites me and i think that's just
what excites people you know that's why
when you see a lot of these rappers
when they um become other things and
they start shying away from it
you don't hear jay-z's name unless he
didn't drop the verse a crazy verse or
he didn't brought another company a
goddess billion dollar check straight up
you don't hear don't worry what is uh
what is you in your opinion the biggest
misconception about the music industry i
think the misconception of the music
industry is that the music industry is
actually the streets and they don't
understand that everybody from the
streets is in the music industries to
get away from the streets
so if you're yeah it's a figment of your
imagination of what you think it is
you know what i'm saying
on some real [ __ ] and i think that's
what it is um don't get it wrong we
still got we still got some of these
youngsters i've seen 21 savage on there
with uh with gilly
and wallow right um
that's probably my favorite podcast by
the
way
gilly i'm coming for your ass i heard
what you said gilly we're going to
address that like stop ducking me set a
date right so
savage was like in y'all era i think a
lot of the rappers was bitch-ass [ __ ]
right they did an art era a lot of these
young rappers really come from that
right i think gilly kind of corrected
him was like well the rapper wanted to
be the street [ __ ]
now the street [ __ ] wants to be the
rapper
yeah back when
we were you know the little young
rappers pull up we out there with our
money algeria cards grill they're like
yo i want to be like big such and such
right also back then less transparency
right so back then it was easier to
be a gangster even if you weren't
because there wasn't social media to
kind of pull your car exactly you really
had to be that
because people heard about it from [ __ ]
that really happened
now you can go do a couple of videos
pull up at a certain spots wear the
right thing be around the right people
pay off the right yeah you're a gangster
we seen it happen with six nine yeah
you know what i'm saying like i was it
was crazy uh shout out to uncle murder i
was listening you know i always go to
this page every day listen to the
wrap-up things like that they had a song
with him six nine uh 50 and uh uh uh
uh young man was somewhat earlier uh the
one that's locked up
casanova casanova right
nine going crazy
he bloody everything's for you know uh
all the [ __ ] went down right
but
you see six nine will [ __ ] cast no
[ __ ] uncle murder uncle murder wanted
realist [ __ ] come out of brooklyn
faction right
50 cent
okay
[ __ ]
what you think that did to that that
kid's head right right right
right and now he starts to lift this
[ __ ] mentally so now his little fans
it's not these other dudes fans
oh yeah he gangsta he was with such a
that was a controlled video
it was a reason why they did that video
it's a different demographics for for
murder and 50 and casanova you know what
i'm saying and if you look on there
she got about 35-40 million streams
right
versus other songs and no right that's
the business of it
you know what i'm saying and this is out
of time why i had a dislike for six nine
when that video happened well yeah
murdered my man yeah game game
yeah
you never got a call from me talking
about why the [ __ ] you doing this video
because i understand that's the business
going on on the 50th floor mm-hmm
i understood the business part of i knew
once that was done and over with murder
was going back to where he going back to
dude was going back to where he was
going back to
what was uh game's thoughts on you doing
the six nine
today he hasn't said nothing to me
which means i haven't
if i get to a point where he think i
went too far he'll tell you he gonna
come knock on my door that's happened
before
oh yeah definitely
yeah he don't give a [ __ ] he
he going look he gonna i'm open the door
and he gonna
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoo
i love you and he gonna walk away get in
this car and go home
he don't bite his tongue with me one bit
what was it uh
maybe an example you could share where
that happened where game was like kind
of kind of give you an earful and some
of some of the [ __ ] you might have said
um
what the [ __ ] was i was doing something
on social media
oh nipsy
i was gonna say was it it had to have
been the nipsy thing you think right it
was nipsy
it was nipsy but he
understood what i was saying
to be clear what you said was nipsey's
not a legend nippy's not a legend in
music in music yeah not in the streets
you know
the streets he's from will dictate and
determine that you know what i'm saying
pretty soon by the way
he died i think you were in the club and
you had the dj play his music i remember
dj i was in chicago yeah i remember i
hadn't played some west coast [ __ ] like
you know
you know i did that i stopped the whole
club i was in chicago i knew me and blue
face and did and just so you know
blueface neighborhood in a neighborhood
don't get along
you know i that could have caused a rift
but i'm in the middle of a blueface club
host and i stopped the whole club
and you know just
you know a moment of silence for nip and
let's play his music and then we went on
about our night but it got to a point to
where
um
game definitely pulled up on me
what'd he say he said bro i understand
everything you said you got your point
across can you please just not say it no
more
i'll tell you and i'm going on
and he rolled out you know what i'm
saying so when that happened
i remember me and head
talking like damn there's some [ __ ]
like we love you wack right but i'm like
there's just some [ __ ] like you could
have kept to yourself
and i think you know and you right but i
think in my life in my
world as fake as all this [ __ ] is
i like to keep it as real as i can
like even if you feel that way right and
i'm not saying i share your opinion
about the nips and [ __ ] but even if you
feel that way and and not to say you
know the the way you laid out your
argument about like ice cube snoop dre
all these yeah
why even put it out there
well they asked me a question
and i think the problem with me is i
don't know how to run
fair enough i'm gonna keep it real i
think if a person asks me a question and
i have a
logical answer
and i say well
like
this answer
them people over there ain't gonna like
i'm gonna say well why are they not
gonna like it am i telling the lie
am i am i disrespecting anybody or is it
i shouldn't say it because of
how they go they telling me i just think
like any time someone is no different
than when i come into home tanks mm-hmm
back then in them days
hey cause they cuz they cuz they cuz
they cuz they cuz they cuz where you
from nine deep [ __ ] this pirate
some people that would have said
nowhere
i couldn't run whatever came with that
it came with that and i think that's
really what my problem is and i know how
to fix the problem i'm fixing the
problem
as far as cause because i always tell my
uh my son fixing the problem you we were
talking about our wives earlier right
and i always i always tell my kid right
my son's 15 and i always say hey look
sometimes i just won't out you got to
just bite your lip and and in in my
household
in my household i call it making a
business decision with my wife
i'm gonna let you have that w i'm gonna
just i'm gonna make the business
decision and not say nothing let you
and you know that's another thing that i
got to work on because you know i'd be
like [ __ ]
you know but women got to do it too with
us sometimes you know they can put up a
great argument but depending on how we
feeling about it and how we reacting to
it they should know like let that go
but i think
my way of fixing that problem is indie
life which is that mobile app is about
ready to launch
to where that's me giving back to the
music community the underground
community which i cater to sunshine
artists right to where
now i don't really have to be a visible
face of it i'll let y'all utilize that
and i'm gonna go on with the next
chapter of my life so i
got rid of all the genes and the jordans
i might keep a couple jaws of wear with
a couple of the suits right and i'm
doing something different to where i'm
not even in that conversation you know
what i'm saying like that like jay-z got
a line on 444.
you know i want to be on the floor where
ain't no real [ __ ] in the room um
really that's where i'm that's that's
what i'm targeted that's hey i think
that should be everyone's
aspirations man because if i'm there and
you ask me i'ma say something so i got i
got to remove myself from being so
accessible to being in front of that did
you resolve any sort because i i know
that there was like speculation that you
had gotten into a scuffle it was it
rolling loud with nipsey's camp yeah now
watch this yeah bossy is
right i'm in lancaster california
got into a fight with some skinny ears
right
somebody had a camera
let me ask you something
you thinking whack how to fight
a whack got
hit and hit the ground
or we was a lockup
we had wrote it loud
there wouldn't be no footage
i mean i i obviously the
i'm just saying right right i'm not even
trying to go down like whether that
happened no it's just real [ __ ] right
right
but they hate me so much
and they want to see me take a loss
so bad
that if a [ __ ] say it
that's what happened
right but even with that you got to
understand it's a million different
stories out there all he disrespect
dipsy uh he said he wasn't from here or
he said
he wasn't a legend he wasn't who he was
to where you're from like you know
people that took it and twisted their
own way
you know i challenge anybody to find any
footage that says anything different
from me addressing
music
because that was really all you were
addressing that's it and that's
obviously it's your opinion it's not my
place to address where you're from i'm
not from where you're from i haven't
kept up with the stats over there
you know what i'm saying we ain't we
ain't did business like that we was
acquainted we talked to each other we
had each other's phone numbers uh we did
some business i helped him with this in
his early career you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] like lax tour
ellie not only that's kate slay i'm the
one putting on new york radio you know
what i'm saying you know a bunch of [ __ ]
like that that tour it's crazy because
that tour was
uh the first time i ever met nip was
that tour he was in i was on radio and
boise
a lot of people like to take credit for
that you know what i'm saying i'm not
going to take the credit for that um
a lot of people like to give big you the
credit for that but ultimately i'm gonna
be real as cocky as nipsy was
he had to want to be over there with
game and it's cocky and as strict as
game is with who's out with him on tour
he had to want that to happen so you
know that's that was a a relationship
mm-hmm you know i'm saying that's why no
game is real genuine about that game did
some [ __ ] he did some [ __ ] the homies
don't like
he took a lamborghini wrapped it in blue
put [ __ ] uh uh
nipsey down one side
and violated everything powerroom
stanford and put crenshaw down the other
side um you know what i'm saying ain't
no power rules on crenshaw
you know what i'm saying but that's the
way he was feeling about his homeboy his
partner i got a million calls about it
man he ain't supposed to listen bro see
that's the difference between
street [ __ ] and industry [ __ ] some
industry [ __ ] some brotherhood [ __ ] also
like you know what i'm saying i ain't
gonna call gamer your game listen man
take that off your car well also like
game is also another example of someone
who's evolved as a human and as a as a
businessman as a
what he represents
something that that has to be that
and that's really not who he represents
himself to be that's where he's from
that's where he came from and all that
but i think people saw a lot of people
bro uh they stuck on the second chapter
and they book a life
summer buff is on our 10th book ninth
chapter so they stuck on the second
chapter this is what it's supposed to be
blood this was supposed to be cuz they
ain't they ain't evolving to writing
these chapters and closing that book out
and going to the next book and evolving
who they gonna be as a man as a father
as a businessman as a homeboy as a
comrade you know what i mean they have
it they they haven't done that so when
we down in our 10th book ninth chapter
they still seen it the way they seen on
their first book second chapter
got a 40 year old 15 year old that's
some real [ __ ] they go to [ __ ] 55 by
default when you combine the two but
then if you average it out it's a whole
nother you know what i'm saying so it's
different
and we see it different you can't argue
with them people because i understand
how you seeing it i totally understand
how you sin because at one point in time
when i was in my first book second
chapter many many moons ago i seen it
that way too but i also see because i'm
on my 10th book knife chapter that you
still down there um
that's some real [ __ ] man that's a mess
that's a bar uh
talk about game i just went over to his
crib like last month he played me i know
he's got this like playlist that he's
going to put out but he's also got his
album that
i don't know if he helped miss crazy i
heard some
crazy
nft and i got to see which way he want
to go with it you know when me and game
do i've our business we sit down and we
bounce ideas around he listens to me i
listen to him we sleep on it and then we
text and then from there that's just
what it's gonna be and then i'll take
the business and whatever we come up
with then that's just what it is you
know what's crazy is like i was even
talking to him just about like
how somehow he's become underappreciated
in the last like 10 years the most under
man i'll be seeing so many top 10
top five
top this and top that like bro there's
very few artists right now that can go
in that studio and outrap that man with
substance
you know what i'm saying all right that
man still records when you hear him
record it ain't a [ __ ] solid and his
discography is untouchable yeah it's
crazy you know i mean gamer still going
to do five six songs bro at night yeah
no problem i think she's got a man that
records
300 songs album i think game is kind of
like uh
an example of someone who just doesn't
play the industry [ __ ] any like like
you know like
there's you you'll go to a [ __ ]
industry event and you'll go to five in
a month and you'll see the same like
artists
he don't play that he don't care about
the war or wars he ain't doing none of
that [ __ ] because he don't
he understands the end like bro that's a
bunch of fake [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean [ __ ] that [ __ ]
mm-hmm yeah you you know i mean let's
get something and do some work and then
you try to hit them they ain't answer
the manager is calling you know with
some [ __ ] so he just like
he deal with who he deal with and like
this what i was telling him i'm like
dude like when it comes to people who
make actual albums
and if we're looking at discography
against discography he's like top five
all time
all day game don't put out whack albums
[ __ ] no it's not gonna happen you could
go through the greatest of all time and
they got some black eyes on their
discography right but like
game when it's a game album
it's always
front to back you press play let that
[ __ ] ride and i think really my my main
um um goal is over the next 12 months
is to help the underground artists and
definitely i need to uh my west coast
artists out here you know it's a lot of
politics and a lot of [ __ ] that um goes
on and they don't have to reach to so i
want to position them so they can win
you know our voices you know the south
been in control yeah man what i'm saying
and they strong down there and they're
going to continue to be
thriving and still be strong but you
know i think that the west could be just
as strong and just as thriving there's
nothing wrong with you know what i mean
every region we go to
it's that dominant strength going on but
it's only gonna happen if we help these
youngsters you know a lot of people out
here in my position as a ceo that
they're playing ceo they got orders up
on them they got movements they just
don't know so it's kind of on me to uh
help get them there i got an obligation
to take blueface and get him
help get him to that next level of being
a superstar you know my up-and-coming
artist uh true car and coyote and you
know what i mean and uh um
you know to help them uh flash gotti
become that um they got a movement down
in compton called rosecrans mm-hmm we
got a maury ruger we got dolby from west
side paroo dobie is is is
really standing in there on the business
side you got mari ruger
you got a tone you know a tone tone um
then they got another kid he from i
think he might be from
forgive me for this it might be from
saint louis or some uh world tour whoa
you might have seen him he was getting
it to a soldier boy he did one said he
filmed soldier boy yeah some crazy [ __ ]
right there so you got that going on
over there but these are movements that
they stay in that pocket because
the resources of them having access to
these blogs and knowing how to do this
and knowing how to do that you know what
i mean they don't know
but but it's there the talent the skill
is there if i put something in front of
you and you interview this person or you
listen to that music in your studio over
there you're like yo this dude dope and
where you been yeah i've been over there
grinding like five years damn no [ __ ]
why do you think that is though cause
like everyone has to
you know they don't want to let nobody
in the people that's in don't don't want
to know but if you really think about
like where the music industry exists now
it's here
like you used to be you could move to
new york and make it you can move but
you got to think about it bro when the
powers to be had the voice
they was letting people in
game
then
um
they did to pass another torch remember
because kendrick can snoop on you yeah
all that to kendrick
right
this [ __ ] then went to a digital world a
total different world to where
i got more of a voice now in this world
than
people i consider to be my legends
because
that ain't a world and that ain't they
lame and you and you play in that world
exactly so you know so now it's a lot of
obligation is on me so you know i got
other things that i'm moving off to uh
moving on to but i'm not gonna just
leave them high in drama make sure i
leave some here a platform here to where
uh it's gonna work for them and help
them get to where they go to expedite it
a little faster you know what i mean you
have a great relationship with p at qc
that's another dude that i watch
he has motivated me because he helps
them youngsters out that gutter
him
gucci mane
i watched them and they made me tell
myself yo i need to step my game up
because they really really help them
youngsters and get them a platform and
i've been to qc studios i don't know
none of these dudes they just up and
coming dudes you know what i'm saying
but they round you know his big artist
so they can see how it go and you know
what i mean and he helping them get
money and position them you know look
look what the the evolution of little
baby yeah it's crazy you know what i'm
saying he didn't went from um the little
dude that come to shoot dice with the
artist at the studio to in the studio to
being one of the hottest in the studio
to now he got artists as hot that's
under him in the studio to where he got
his own label situation and you know he
blew printed off of what he seen pete do
with him and peace supporting him and
they supporting each other so you know
he's he's really one of the ones that
yeah i think i look at like what he's
doing and like look at what yo gotti's
doing birdman too you know bird boys of
course you know very certain guys that i
see what they doing to where i feel like
i got an obligation to step to the plate
what about you know i know you and top
got a great relationship obviously you
know tde being the
i guess kind of the closest thing we've
had to death row since death row yeah
definitely top dog is definitely one of
my mentors one of my g homies and i
don't say that about everybody
um he's definitely somebody that when
i'm in a bind
or i need to make a decision or i'm kind
of at odds about which way i should go
with somebody somebody i call because i
definitely um respect his opinion and um
um you see the
the leadership you know and uh
the class he showed with kendrick just
being kendrick's last album you know
what i'm saying you know if you're
paying attention
he just then woke up and got back on the
gas you know what i mean he got um
rayvon rayvon rayvon
him and kendrick in top and uh j-rock
and top came with the studio with true
car and gave me a bank ray bonds of
beasts man we had him on the show we had
so ray von lived in arizona for a little
bit okay so one of my arizona homies man
has been managing forever yeah so ray
vaughan came on me and head show like
three or four years ago good dude good
dude he's a beast funny as hell too
he doesn't oh his tickets are little
[ __ ] hilarious little uh his diary
yeah he's hello yeah but see
into artists pay attention to rayvon
because not only is he a beast and i
want to say nephew from long beach he's
from long beach here he's from long
beach right and i can't i don't know if
he gang bangs or not every time
yeah but
he also is not scared to show his sense
of humor and be himself you know what
i'm saying in that sense humors was
translating to tick tock which is
growing his fan base and then when you
listen to his music it's real it's
authentic his street is real so you know
some people is too gangster for this
[ __ ] today i tell you if you two gangsta
i can't do nothing for you and you're
too gangster to have a sense of humor or
something the kids want to talk about
and laugh about it tick tock too
i can't i can't do nothing with you
because i can't do those things right
right right right yeah you can't be
funny and no i can take your i can take
your product and i can put it
in places that you can't but i you got
to create the product i i really do
think like ray vaughn is like kind of an
evolution of kendrick right because like
kendrick is obviously to the point i
always say there's like so listen listen
listen
like there's only one game there's only
one kendrick no but what i was going to
say was that i think rayvon is talented
enough
to one day we'll be sitting here saying
there's only one that's what i was gonna
say like if you think of kendrick right
kendrick is
in my opinion top five all time that's
my personal opinion my personal opinion
right i agree i always tell people if
you got biggie in your top five and he
only put out two albums how the [ __ ]
don't you got kendrick in your time you
know the first time i heard kendrick
when
was in new york top dog them came out
there they were just moving around i
introduced them to k-slate um shaq and
my guy money mark was doing this uh
thing in long island everybody was there
bun b all everybody was there performing
and [ __ ] like that
and
[ __ ] papoose had got up there
j-rock went
papoose get up there and does that ends
his set with alphabetical slaughter
right classic grace mixtape classic
kendrick at the time who was
[ __ ]
yep sitting over there the shy guy
you know he's looking at me and i'm
looking at him i'm looking at top i'm
like top right he's like yeah he like
you want to go up there after that he's
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
you sure you want to go up there after
that
pat pools in new york in new york right
he like yeah yeah yeah yeah right
and he went up there and you know you
get up there get somebody to mike you
kind of fade to the left you talking and
right when he started going i'm like
what the [ __ ] i look at top i say top
that's the one yeah that the first time
i heard kendrick get down was when he
came behind papoose in new york
and papua's gonna make it hard for you
he'll make it hard for anybody yeah so
especially i'm sure i'm assuming this
was like oh six somewhere like that yeah
this is like
peak papoose yeah
and it was then so that was my first bar
of uh
kendrick lamar yeah i just think
kendrick like his lyrical proudness and
like you know kendrick is on a level
kind of where cole's at right where like
they don't need to be on tick-tock no
i'm not even there i'm the present
they're omnipresent but i think ray von
has the opportunity to be
the like lyrical
person that's kind of
you know when we look when we think of
the young like generation right i think
you can think of chordae you can think
of a few guys who are kind of who can
get down with the bars right but i think
ray vaughn has an opportunity he's got
that edgy [ __ ] to him like he like you
know like our true car got that edgy
[ __ ] to him you know you need that pain
ray von's got the rayvon played a song i
don't know if it's ever going to come
out but he played a song that like made
me tear up in the studio because it was
about when he lost his baby mom
and it was crazy and i'm like man he's
got this but then he also has
the social media [ __ ] on a lot cause
he's [ __ ] hilarious he's funny as
[ __ ] man that damn
dear diary [ __ ] he does bro
that [ __ ] caught me off guard one day i
didn't know what he was doing i spit all
my food i'm like what the [ __ ] some of
your mama boo booed on myself like what
the [ __ ]
you know what i mean but yeah but he has
a sense of humor man shout out to ray
vaughn he's gonna be something top's got
one for sure man tde gonna continue to
uh hey look at isaiah look at isaiah
rashford doing the numbers
are coming again i've seen something
about something popped up on scissors
you know what i mean j-rock's still over
there of course you know i mean uh
schoolboy q
um
and uh the the other nephew from uh from
carson
he's a beast
absolutely yeah absolutely absolute all
right
he's an alien he goes in the studio
absolutely
puts his arms behind his back and goes
yeah absolutely yeah um would you ever
do a podcast yourself wack they've been
reaching for me to do it academics that
uh he hinted around maybe i'll do some
with him um
my guy's a paradigm fred andrew ruff
they've been in conversation with but a
few platforms so yeah i definitely would
consider it i wouldn't i wouldn't mind
it'd be another platform but i would
like want to i would want to i would
want to put the attention on those
people that they can't see um you know
what i'm saying you know i mean like
give your share your platform with some
people people who really benefit off it
drake
was once one of those guys that people
couldn't see
you know you never know you know it's
out there it's a lot of them out there
so i would definitely want to put my
attention on
uh on those if i did my podcast we could
mix in the common [ __ ] right but i would
want to be that gateway to the
underground artists you know what i mean
the underground producers you know the
management those cos i've been coming to
put some light on them
you talked about how when you first
signed blueface you helped get his
credit together helped him get to the
house let's say you signed somebody
today
and they got a 500 credit score
what is your like what do you
how do you help them get their [ __ ]
together because i think that this is
one of the more under under appreciated
things
i saw the music in the streets you know
i'm a businessman yes so you know shout
out to my man travis wilson that's the
secret to my success trying for the
stars following him on instagram um i'm
definitely gonna
have them pull a profile and i'll have
my team sit down and we're going to look
at everything they have going on and
these are costs and expenses that i
i absorb i don't charge this back to
them
you know what i mean we're going to look
at what's going on with them we're going
to get them right you know i mean a lot
of these they come and they got [ __ ]
repos and lates they don't know they
just yeah i get to call them out you
know i pay when i pay it so i definitely
want to get them right with that you
know you know you can't be running
around here with no medical and [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying you got need dental
work done you need to do that a lot of
you artists for real
y'all got ten thousand dollars of
clothes on two hundred thousand dollars
a jury yo listen i know you got used to
looking at yourself like that yo bro go
go to the dentist spend your [ __ ]
teeth together get get your teeth
together man just real [ __ ] man y'all
need to definitely do that and make sure
that your kids don't come up the way you
come up cause you used to seeing
yourself like that and make sure you
keep them right and keep them together
you know what i mean so
um you know it's just about you know i
want them to be a reflection of me and
then grow to become better than me
that's fair um anatomy
you know segwaying
how you you know we were just talking
about how your daughter you know
unfortunately she tore achilles he just
tore a killer um but you always you know
you're a guy why a texture i'm like yo i
met kaiser with my you're a great father
man like you know whether your daughter
has a cheerleading competition in vegas
you're there
you always say like you know i want my
daughter like i want my children to not
follow in my footsteps my son would be
better than me like me and my son kind
of we we hit a rough patch a couple
months ago you know what i mean but he's
right there at that stage and where he's
sitting in his way and i'm seeing how
old is he
20 just turned 27
right but you know
he's been man in the house all this time
because i'm not there half the time man
my wife we here there there whatever
right
um
but you know we hit a rough pastor where
you know
um he did something that i respected he
did
i came home one day and he was gone
you know what i'm saying
he was gone but at this on the flip side
what i'm gonna do make him come home
man grown right you know i didn't gave
him everything i can give him but i'm
still here to give him some more he know
i'm here if he slipping and falling but
catch him when i got him but you know
just the fact that he stepped out there
let me know okay you know he manning up
you know what i'm saying he's man it up
do you how do your kids feel about your
public persona
um
they really don't say nothing to me
about it because you know me my kids
growing up around me i never
heard who i was they're like that's just
dad just see no they don't yeah they you
know
um
they'll come tell me certain things or
sometimes they'll know when i did
something because they because it's on
the internet their phone goes crazy the
people you know i mean people won't
answer this but you know they don't
really say too when they don't really
pay no attention because they they watch
me i like people be thinking i'm serious
half the time when i'm doing it i'm like
they knowing i'm doing something because
i'm laughing while i'm doing it and then
the world just takes it very very
serious
which answers my question to where the
perception of the
industry
right people don't know what's real and
what's faith
that's real
that's crazy because like you had said
earlier like six nine kind of ex his
mission is to expose
quote unquote the streets right that's
his mission and well it shouldn't be
because if you know that they're not
coming for you and you ain't got the
people with you you should just take
that as an opportunity just live your
life
well i was gonna say like how much of
what he's saying is true is in terms of
the quote-unquote streets kind of and
the industry like you said right the
perception is that they're both the same
when they're not right no definitely not
so isn't what he's trying to do kind of
exposing what you're saying is the
biggest misconception
it's definitely it's it's it's not just
listen man
i don't
advise
any of the youth
to get a life to the streets
the first chance and first opportunity
you have
to get out of the streets to get out of
together whether it's going to college
whether it's a foreign exchange program
in another country whether you go to the
military or the police academy
i'm telling you take that route take
that lane
i need more of our youth from that's
crips and blood orientated uncles
brothers that got eight nine generations
of this [ __ ] to go to the police academy
we steadily complaining about how they
doing us when they pull us over i want
somebody to pull me over that
understands where i come from that's not
nervous that comes from the same places
that's not nervous and jittery and and
got their lunch money took you know only
way we gonna turn it around is to put
some of us in there yeah i think that
you can't take the house without getting
in the house right how are you ever
going to change it if you're not that's
what we got to do i don't i haven't
i haven't made the decision of being
part of the decision making in over 25
years of somebody getting put on my
neighborhood
and then my homeboy is just gangbang
that i run across i don't even allow
them to call me big homie
because i don't want to have no gang
association of ties
with you like that because that ain't
what i want for you
if
you had it if i had it my way
it wouldn't be nobody else initiated
from this day forward
and hopefully 10 15 20 years from now
it'll all phase out and we just be one
as a people um yeah man i just don't
like you cause i don't like you not
because of what somebody did 10 years
ago that's from the same place we're
from
i mean that's really what paige i'm on
if you really want to know yeah man i
think that's i mean that's that's
hopefully that rubs off on a lot of this
generation i'm not going to denounce
that i'm a thug and i and i come from
that gangster should not come from and i
ain't going to never denounce that cause
i ain't ashamed and i think that's what
made me who i am today to be able to
have these type of conversations that
had the type of influence that i have on
some of these youngsters i don't
denounce it but i'm not gonna be one to
sit here and be a hypocrite and say
that's the way to go cause some of us
didn't make it out
yeah it's real man
that's real i think uh just keeping it
100 on the 100 episode on the 100th
episode so what is the latest with
blueface fighting six nine is it for
sure
they both agreed to it um it's probably
gonna be something that happens in the
middle east you just get the funds up
because triller for that to happen no
you notice a lot of my investors in
saudi and bahrain and qatar is coming to
the table with it because you know
that's gonna be a big big bag a real
real big bag blueface is probably gonna
mop him up for sure i mean listen i got
all faith that blueface is gonna win the
fight i saw yeah blueface could not like
has hands his face could fight yeah he
can fight he can box and he'll have
learned you know a valuable lesson when
it comes to training our little inside
jokes something i know that he won't do
a violate again you know i mean would
you ever step in the ring as a celebrity
at a celebrity fight definitely depend
on you know if the bag is right and
you'll definitely get it my money is on
you
i'm gonna i we i'm not gonna box we're
gonna lock up it's gonna i'm gonna try
to get it out the way quick
i i've never been a boxer i've been a
brawler you know what i mean so that's
what that is you know i'm gonna call on
mike to train me my partner mike tyson
you know what i'm saying i definitely
might gonna be my trainer
what is mike tyson like uh yeah cool as
[ __ ] real
real don't know who he is
mike has no not to say he don't know who
he is as a person he doesn't understand
who he is to the world don't give a [ __ ]
about that all that famous mike type yo
whack let's go to the store he's a
[ __ ] car we can't get in the car
we're mike tyson yeah walk to the store
yeah you know i'm cool as hell laid back
down the earth
and he gonna speak his mind
has he convinced you to try any
psychedelic swac because you know he's a
psychedelic guy you know i don't know
everybody know i don't do nothing so no
i know you don't do nothing but
psychedelics are different not [ __ ]
with that i no nobody wants to see me do
anything
i think it's imagine i think you're
gonna see uh
no i don't want to see you
edible i don't want to see you no what
is that mushrooms oh hell no i think you
could cut through and really grow
that's out
you wouldn't you wouldn't do a shroom
trip with mike tyson no i'm not doing
man what i think i'll die no you won't
die yeah you'll be reborn kids do not
listen to this type of conversation this
is peer-press you know what i want to
touch on this too man like
because um
we got a situation going on in our
streets with the drugs man
rest in peace to michael k williams yeah
good dude man good i was just
i just got through watching chalky white
man boardwalk empire one of his best
characters
but
the kids y'all need to understand i
don't know if y'all know what russian
roulette is russian roulette when they
take a revolver they put one bullet in
there and they spin the chamber and they
click the gun and if that bullet
lies in the wrong spot you're dead
you're dead right
these days
these people that are manufacturing
these drugs are lacing these drugs with
this fentanyl right and the people that
you are buying these drugs from they
don't know they don't if they laced or
not and they gonna tell you i got the
pure [ __ ] but they don't know playing
russian roulette with your life
taking these pills
tootiness even doing coke man i strongly
advise you guys to stop
you take it you go to sleep you don't
wake up period period right
and and
i really strongly advise you guys to
look into yourself to ask yourself is
this drug this pill or whatever it may
be
worth the risk of you possibly not
waking up
i think if you look at the
legends we've lost
in the last three or four years
i mean there was a a comedian that
passed away that was like this i got to
correct myself because i was real
ignorant to what this this uh fentanyl
was and i think i could be wrong i think
this might be what killed uh mac miller
it is right and when mac miller died i
made a statement like yo that's on him
that man know what he was doing taking
all these drugs he overdosed i was under
the impression that dude was just
abusing just doing a bunch now i think
he took
the wrong [ __ ] the wrong [ __ ] drug so
um you know i want to you know my
apologies man you know what i mean cause
i really i was really ignorant to what
fettner was i didn't know you know like
that's that's not a some household [ __ ]
in the streets did you see the video of
the cop who took a whiff of it on a stop
and they he almost died on the side of
the street
he was in san diego this is serious bro
that's why i tell my kids you don't
accept a tylenol it's the cheapest [ __ ]
right and it stretches it like it
stretches your yes imagine if you have a
kilo of coke and you're a drug dealer
five you can stretch it times five crazy
[ __ ] but the problem is you're gonna
kill how many people you're gonna
[ __ ] kill i'm not gonna lie man
listen to all our rappers out here
that's influencing the kids
a lot of it gonna start with y'all man
because y'all are glorifying it and i
know y'all not going fine using drugs
that have fentanyl but the fact that
this is how they sneak it in on us you
doubted me you know
maybe y'all need to be a little more
educational about it i can't tell y'all
what to do what to say how to live your
life but we all got little brothers you
know what i mean we all got family you
know what i mean where maybe we might
want to educate them to where yeah i i i
take zanny it is
you know this [ __ ] is getting bad you
may want to eliminate you know what i
mean uh
doing this because of what's going on
with it you know i mean you know just
you know just my reach to all you
rappers that yeah i just saw uh
you know i was i was watching an episode
of joe rogan uh that just came out and
he was talking about uh michael k
williams who died and obviously there
were some comedians in a house in venice
where i'm still low up in there because
i'm hearing cocaine i'm hearing heroin
i i don't know
so i'm hearing this cocaine right as far
as like dude this is the day before the
comedians the comedians in venice oh
[ __ ] right doing i mean look at the end
of the day
i've i've i've never done cocaine in my
mind i'm the only drugs i've ever done
the house
but you know how it is you've been in a
situation where everyone's passing
around a plate of coke i've witnessed
that i've never participated in it but
just imagine [ __ ] lakes with the
fentanyl everybody who hits it is on the
ground it's gone
but but joe rogan was saying like
what what probably is the like uneasy
truth that people aren't going to want
to like admit to as far as politicians
is like you got to legalize all drugs so
the product at least is controlled
because people are going to do drugs
either way right fentanyl is hey look
they catch you with that [ __ ] they
giving you life they put you in under
the [ __ ] prison catch you with that
fat no that [ __ ] is like what pcp was on
steroids they catch you with that you
out of here yeah man and it's crazy
because there's no way to there's no
quality control
in the drugs in drugs anymore oh wow
what's the quality control i don't know
because even
that's what i'm saying all i know is the
[ __ ] ain't for us it ain't for my people
nobody's people it ain't for our youth
man and we really need to start
educating these kids
on what fentanyl is
and what it will do to you if they
happen
to be it
because i don't think they know i didn't
know at one point in time right
yeah it is russian it's literally russia
russian roulette bro if you get it
it's over so
yeah it's crazy man yeah you know what
i'm saying so we definitely need to do
that i hear you back at radio oh yeah
yeah yeah that's what we're talking
about we launched you know we launched
the syndicated show back at back in real
ninety two three even the real ninety
two three doing this thing you know
seeing the podcast grow i got let go and
then back on the station it's seven
months where they do that at oh did you
like get let go
what you ventured off to do
right you went back to radio with that
yeah what you was doing you know what i
mean so now it ain't like you had to
shut this down this is part of that the
way i looked at what happened with me
was
i had already had the thought in my mind
to leave terrestrial radio and launch my
own syndicated show because i see that
that's where the business is heading
right so when everything happened you
know for people who don't know i got let
go in december for budget cuts right i
heart
laid off like two thousand people or
something actually so i got laid off but
i i didn't i wasn't emotional about it i
was like hey thank you doc for the look
thank you a.o kept my relation i'm like
look i told ao i said look you know i'm
launching this radio show
and you know i got put on in vegas at
first at ao station in vegas and then
you know just put my head down and got
to it and
an opportunity presented itself you
always been a real one you know
attention being a real one so you know
it ain't gonna stop you bro like i'm
gonna be real you know your best is yet
to come yeah man i feel that i mean i i
i value our relationship because i know
it's gonna come a day while i'm walking
in somewhere and it's going the decision
going to be up to bootleg care and i'm a
value that i got 15 20 25 years in with
this man you know what i mean so it's
like you know that's how i build my
relationships with people so you know i
see it in you you understand this
business you taking your hits in this
business yeah you bounce back for this
business and i know you're still
reaching into this business so you know
the best for you you have to come man
yeah i would just tell everyone man bet
on yourself because literally that's all
i did i just went all in on me i said
i'm gonna launch a radio show and we
launched with kkfr as our first
affiliate in phoenix and now you know
we're on seven stations
probably about to be like 15 real soon
that's great did my youtube [ __ ] let
y'all know
my little brother ray j my business
partner he's still working he loves to
give back to the community ray j's
election how's this rages allegedly has
this safe sex campaign going on he got
his new his new line of radronics no we
got new condoms coming up there's gonna
be ray j condoms he's got condoms it
better be magnum size because we've seen
the video
i don't know nothing about that
you didn't watch the sex tape no listen
you didn't see the sex tape all i know
is this kanye holla at me bro we got
part two on the laptop ain't never been
seen we'd love for you to have it it'd
be a great personal private nft you know
wait wait wait wait wait so there's
another
ray j kim k sex tape
that's that we haven't seen yeah that
was more graphic and better than the
first one
is it ever going to see the light of day
i mean i wouldn't me personally i would
never give it to anybody but kanye
because that's
he's got ki it's a mother is children
there's a lot of people that didn't try
to reach for that for a price tag
obviously kanye could buy it from you or
would you just give it to him you know
what i i probably would because it's
kanye i i probably would give it to
kanye because it's kanye is ray j in the
same mind state as you cause that's my
little brother you know he made we might
wake up one day and rage is like [ __ ] it
nah nah because you know onlyfans.com
forward slash rachel remember ray j's a
father now too yes yes yes you
understand what i'm saying so and ray j
really ain't a boss he's a you know he's
a great he's a great guy so you know
that's i think we would probably gift
that to him
you know what i'm saying if ever that
day was to come we was just saying we
would give that to him he got money he
got children by that one you've seen the
part two i mean we've been in our life
10 11 12. so you've seen the unreleased
kim quartz what do you mean
wow and it was better than the first one
longer all that
wow
hey well listen
uh
kanye tapping with whack 100 yeah we'll
get that to him we you know that just
that's for him you know i mean we can't
put that out there in the world like
that be disrespectful
in worst case scenario kanye becomes the
president in like eight years and you
want to hit like a billion dollar lick
i'm just saying i'm just saying you know
i personally wouldn't be that you know
what's bigger than kanye and kim what
those children i understand the internet
that is true man they got kids i gonna
have it not on my watch hey man that's
what makes you different whack you know
what i'm saying so whack 100 episode 100
of the bullet head podcast
west up
ending with a [ __ ]
just a huge revelation
so let's go let's go let's go let's go
shout out to all my family my loved ones
everybody out there that support me
incredible diapers coming my man steve
marcano 50 wait wait is it 15 hours of
uh
uh soaking up that [ __ ] is crazy man
incredible diapers people they're like
yo my babies my kids i waking up at
night because they dry wow spent a lot
of money i really shout out to american
gangster american gangster inspired me
to do what i did because i went frank
lucas and went to the source like i went
to china i mean my pipe was in the
pickup and my business partnered travis
wilson when he was in the pickup and
going straight to where they make the
diapers
and we went out there right there they
witnessed it you know what i mean it was
crazy so you know they could have made a
left and a right my ass would never
count you would have never been wouldn't
know there it is man
whack 100 episode 100 the blackhead
podcast
and
i'm gonna leak something out okay cause
instagram been tripping y'all stay tuned
live on the lookout for insta
insta rated
coming soon it's the what insta-rated
well they took your ig down for a bit
take it every two weeks recycling
because i saw your instagram after the
six nine [ __ ] which was gone and then it
came back and there was this this
profile that had like eighteen thousand
followers and people watching me that
wasn't even that ain't me whack 100
officials not me it's a fake page they'd
be getting people to send them money for
consulting fees and all that do not send
them nothing but you know it's getting
to a point where i said watch what they
do with bootsy and a few other artists
is like you know i got a nice little
tech team shout out to my man say my man
sam with brave energy drink um we didn't
put our tech team together we didn't we
bought about two million lines of code
in so you might you can be launching
your own social platform oh definitely
indy life is coming insta-rated it's
coming there it is uncensored there it
is black
there it is
post whatever you want
i'm saying get your money boom west up